Excellent Chat, noch keiner da, Anzeige ist raus, direkt Abmahnung verschickt.
So, ja da muss ich mal warten bis Twitch registriert hat, dass er stream online ist.
Guck mal der Phipps ist schon da oder der zweite, Phipps der zweite ist am Start.
Irgendwie habe ich Dreck auf meiner Tastatur, was ist das hier, was soll das, ah jetzt
hier geht es aber los, guckst du einmal nicht auf den Bildschirm und auf einmal ist der
Chat voll, der Titel macht mir Angst, mir auch, mir auch, mir auch, aber ich bin mal
gespannt, es wird Pains Champion, das weiß ich genau, Massive Pains Champion wird es
heute, Tuning Pack von meinem Zahnarzt, das könnte sein, das wird es auch ausprobieren,
ja, ich habe mir ein paar Sachen rausgesucht und zwar, also Leute ich zeige euch mal kurz,
was ich mir überlegt habe, ah ja ja, Weeps in oder Weeps out ist die Frage, Moin ich
möchte mir einen V-Server mieten, wo kann ich das am besten machen, tja dazu würde
ich sagen, gehst du einfach über meinen Werbelink zu Hetzner und holst dir einen 20 Euro Gutschein,
damit kannst du dir schon glaube 4 Monate, 4 Monate einen ganz brauchbaren Server mieten.
Ich bin mal gespannt, also Leute, ich habe ja gestern, was bittet die Tuning Packs mit
EE Search, ich weiß nicht, also ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen andere Musik anmachen,
also ich habe ja gestern ein Video gemacht, auf YouTube oder YouTube wie das manche Leute
nennen, was ich bis heute nicht verstehe, aber es gibt Leute die sagen das, ich weiß
das glaubt ihr mir aber nicht, glaubt ihr mir nicht, aber es ist real, so, ähm, sag
mal, Leute, ist die Schrift anders im Chrome, mit der Schrift stimmt doch irgendwas nicht,
das ist doch nicht die normale YouTube Schrift, haben die auf YouTube ihre Schrift geändert?
Sag mal, das ist nicht der normale Font, ne, oder, oder bin ich jetzt total blöd, sag
mal, das ist anders, der, der Font ist anders, bisschen, bisschen anders, ich kann sich wirklich,
oh, wirklich greifen, alter YouTube, so, was ist denn das für ein Font, sieht man das
irgendwo gescheit, aber was ist, kann man das, ich glaube im Firefox sieht man das besser,
sieht man irgendwo was das für ein Font ist, hier, Roboto ist es, ja, aber das sieht doch
anders aus, das sieht anders aus, der Font, Leute, guckt euch das mal im Stream an, sieht
das bei euch anders aus, als bei euch, oder, oder bin ich einfach nur verwirrt und es
sieht, sieht, sieht gar nicht anders aus, ja gut, ich mein bei mir ist größer, ihr
habt es wahrscheinlich auf 100%, ja, das ist, hast du das Video von Morpheus Tutorial zu
dem Stream Thema gesehen, ne, aber wahrscheinlich sagt er das gleiche wie ich, dass solche Tuning
Packs bescheuert sind, schick mal Link, Blitz, so, warte mal, ich muss jetzt mal kurz mit
Firefox vergleichen, wenn du übrigens beim Vorschauen bist lustig, irgendwie hat das
keiner so richtig zur Kenntnis genommen, ja der Font, der Font im Firefox ist auch anders
als der Font im Chrome, aber es gab auch eben ein Chrome Update vor 5 Minuten, ja, ja ok
vor 21 Stunden aber ich hab eben geupdatet, warte zumindest, ich lese gleich Chat, Leute,
zumindest wie ich drauf gekommen bin diese ganzen Tuning Pakete mal auszuprobieren, ihr
wisst, ich halte davon auch nix, aber, welches Tuning Paket, ich zeige euch mal was ich für
Tuning Pakete mir rausgesucht hab, Moment, also, Loadpad was sonst, also ich hab einfach
mal geguckt was die Leute in den Kommentaren empfohlen haben, ist jetzt kein Witz, also
die Dinger wurden mehr oder weniger in den Kommentaren genannt, paar Sachen musste ich
ein bisschen forschen was die Leute meinen, so, aber diese Dinger wurden in den Kommentaren
genannt, irgendwie ein komischer Uninstaller der Geld dafür haben will, Deploater Scripts
und zwei komplette Windows ESOs die angeblich deploatet sind und getunt, da bin ich ja mal
gespannt, also wie gesagt Leute, ich würde sowas nicht verwenden normalerweise, weil
du gar nicht so genau weißt was da eigentlich ausgeführt wird, ja, es sei denn die Scripts
in Open Source und du liest dir jetzt alles vorher durch was wahrscheinlich keiner machen
wird, aber das probieren wir mal aus, getuntes ESO, ja es gibt getunte ESOs, also das hier
sind wohl ESOs, das hier sind wohl ESOs soweit ich das gesehen hab, das sind Tuning Scripts
oder Uninstaller oder was auch immer, ich verwende sowas normalerweise nicht, ich halte
da eigentlich auch nix davon, aber ich hab mir gedacht ey, so viele Leute wie das in
dem Video geschrieben hab ich wirklich, ich muss mir das einfach mal angucken, ich weiß
dass man das selber bilden kann aber das mach ich nicht, ja wo kommen wir denn dahin, ja
das kann ich machen aber das mach ich im Stream hier jetzt nicht, pack noch Tronsk, was für
so ein Ding, was ist Tronskript, was ist das, PC Cleanup, da muss man irgendwas von Reddit
runterladen, es wird ja immer noch mysteriöser langsam, ich lad mir doch keine Butter-Type
von Reddit runter, und würde die dann aus, was ist mit den Leuten verkehrt, Butter-Type
von Reddit, ja ja super Vertrauenszwecken sieht das alles aus, also ich mach mal kurz
ein neues Browser, Broser Fenster auf, achso das vergesse ich ja immer, dass das nicht
richtig funktioniert, Track und Droppen mit Chrome, das geht tatsächlich mit Firefox
in dem Fall besser, also was wir uns heute angucken ist einmal das da, ich hab alles
noch nie ausprobiert, ich hab kein Schimmer davon, ja, irgendwie so ein cleaner Ding wurde
empfohlen in den Comments, dann das da wurde empfohlen in den Comments, das hatten wir
sogar schon mal auf im Stream, guck mal das hat 10.000 GitHub Sterne, das kann ich sagen,
dann das da, so und die anderen Sachen hab ich über GitHub gefunden, das ist in Deepload
GUI, noch irgendein anderes Deeploads Script und hier gibt es irgendwie ein Deeploaded
ISO und ein Deeploaded Script, das ist mein Zahnarzt hier by the way, und dann gibt es
hier irgendwie auch noch eine fertige ISO, kein Schimmer was da was ist, aber ich würd
fast sagen, wir fangen mal mit was normalem an, wir fangen mal mit was normalem an, wir
nehmen mal was, was man irgendwie eventuell auch noch benutzen könnte und zwar wir nehmen
einfach das Projekt mit 10.000 Sterne auf GitHub und wir installieren übrigens in Windows
Home, zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben installiere ich in Windows 10 Home, haben wir noch nie
gemacht, am Ende nochmal alle Scripts nacheinander laufen lassen, das ist eine gute Idee, das
kann man machen, guck mal hier haben wir ein Windows installiert, für was ist das? Für
was ist das? Resume. Für was ist das? Gucken wir mal ein paar VMs mal löschen so langsam,
ist das die WSL Test VM? Ne, was für ne VM war das hier? Der hätte Windows jetzt so
ne History was wir zuletzt gemacht haben, ok ich mach Chrome History gucken was wir zuletzt
gemacht haben, dann kann ich euch sagen was es für ne VM war, das ist bestimmt die Porn
VM, wahrscheinlich ja, eh, Recuva was zum, ok ich weiß nicht was es für ne VM ist, ich
glaub nicht das wir die noch brauchen, Power Off BAM und einfach jetzt Windows installieren,
Hot Tube Stream, was haben wir hier? 3 CPUs, 4GB RAM, ach komm Leute BAM 8G RAM, haben
wir genug, soll er ordentlich flutschen, soll er ordentlich, ordentlich, ach das ist, ich
weiß wofür wir das haben, das ist die Windows VM, wo wir mal die Platte restored haben,
die es, die es gekillt hat, weil ich es einfach ausgeschaltet hab, was für ne PC hast du?
Ich hab ein 8700K, 2, eh muss ich mal gucken, ich glaube 32G RAM, Zack, Zack, hier, also
6 CPU Kerne, 32G RAM und ein paar SSDs, also das reicht dafür. Kannst du eine non Mono
Font empfehlen für Schriften im Browser? Ne, ich nehm immer die Fault, die Fault Zeug.
So, wir haben doch bestimmt noch ne Windows ISO hier irgendwo rumliegen, ich hab so viele
Windows ISOs schon downloadet, die müssen, hier muss doch irgendwo was sein, da ist doch
guck mal hier, User, ISO, wie, ist weg? Wo ist mein Windows ISO? KegWaite HD, ok dann
machen wir das übliche, wie jeden Stream wo es um Windows geht, Windows ISO Download
und ihr wisst was ich jetzt sage oder, ihr wisst was ich jetzt zeige, ich zeige euch
das was ich euch immer so zeige, weil jedes mal die Leute sagen, ho guck mal da, das wusste
ich ja gar nicht, also normalerweise kann man keine Windows ISO runterladen hier ne,
es geht um Millimeter, das Ding hab ich mir auch hier aufgeschrieben ja und jetzt, und
jetzt klickt man hier auf Inspect, geht auf die Mobile Seite, Refresh die Seite, macht
es wieder zu und siehe da man kann ISO downloaden, krasser Hacker Mensch Scheiß oder? So, wir
wollen das auf Englisch international bestätigen, 64, wobei 64 Bit ist eigentlich schon ein
bisschen zu plaudet oder was meint ihr? Überlegt mal 32 Bit kannst du auf der 64 Bit CPU doppelt
so viel Sachen ausführen, also eigentlich sollte man besser 32 Bit nehmen, 16 Bit sogar
vierfach, ja deswegen, genau das ist, ja auf, mach hin, genau mein Reden Chat, genau mein
Reden, deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum es Windows 10 nicht als 16 Bit gibt, ich meine
es braucht doch nicht jeder über 4 Gigabyte RAM, einfach als 16 Bit machen und viermal
so viel ausführen, überlegt euch mal, da machst du aus einem 6 Core ein 24 Core, deswegen
verstehe ich es nicht, es braucht nicht jeder so viel RAM, der Deep Loader macht 16 Bit,
ach deswegen funktioniert das so gut, verstehe ich, verstehe ich, 8 Bit, na 8 Bit ist dann
schon zu wenig, 16 Bit war das beste, deswegen ist ja auch der Super Nintendo meine Lieblingskonsole.
So, was macht der Download? Und 24 Core, weil 4 GHz sind 96 GHz, alter Chat, also wir haben
hier schon teilweise Noobs, als könnte man die GHz Zahl der Cores zusammenrechnen, also
ich meine es ist allgemein bekannt, dass man das bei 32 Bit zu 64 Bit machen kann, aber
doch nicht bei der GHz Zahl von den Cores, ne, also manchmal frage ich mich auch, hat
der Chat gar nichts gelernt die letzten Streams, ja? Anonymous Chira hat 16 Cent gecheert,
dankeschön, das zusammenrechnen machen die beim Media Markt, oh ja, beim Media Markt,
ich habe mir mal fast in die Hose gemacht, als ich zum Media Markt gefahren bin und im
Stau gestanden habe, aber das will ich jetzt nicht näher ausführen, wobei ich glaube
das habe ich euch eh schon mal erzählt, ist auf jeden Fall Pains Champ. Tell me more,
das habe ich euch doch schon mal erzählt, oder? Das habe ich euch doch schon mal erzählt,
das war, als ich meinen allerersten Rechner gekauft habe, mit meinem Vater zusammen, den
hatten wir, egal, jetzt müsste er, cool StoryBob, jetzt müsste er nochmal durch, bis der Download
fertig ist, als ich mir meinen ersten Rechner gekauft habe, das war, ne stimmt nicht, es
war nicht der erste Rechner, aber es war der erste selbst bezahlte Rechner, wo ich dann
quasi bei Mutter, Opa, Oma, Vater, Patentante und so das Geld zusammen gebettelt habe über
2 Jahre, somit, frag mich nicht, 14 oder so, kann man ganz einfach ausrechnen, Pentium
2 400, wann kam das Ding raus, wann kam der Pentium 2 raus, P2 Release Date, kann ich
euch sagen, wie alt ich da war, also, kann man das, Google nicht einfach was finden,
1998, ok, 1998 war ich 14, passt doch, habe ich schon auch gute Erinnerungen, sagen wir
mal, vielleicht ein Jahr später, 14, 15, 14 glaube ich war ich da, so, und da hatte
ich quasi das komplette Geld zusammen gebettelt schon, und 2000 Mark hat der Rechner gekostet
und da gab es bei MediaMarkt ein Angebot, Pentium 2, 400 Megahertz, Rest weiß ich gar
nicht mehr, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich glaube, ich glaube 1,2G Festplatte, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, was man damals hatte als Festplatte, als Disc, das könnte sogar schon, nee, nee,
das müsste mehr gewesen sein als 1,2, das müsste mehr gewesen sein, ohne ordentlich
RAM, ohne halbwegs brauchbare Grafikal, also der Rechner war gar nicht so schlecht, zumindest
haben wir uns den reserviert und das war damals ein riesen Antrag bei MediaMarkt, dass die
uns das gar nicht reservieren wollten, mein Vater hatte die Überrede dazu, dass die uns
das reservieren, die haben gesagt, ja, wir müssen irgendwie 15 Uhr da sein, und da sind
wir losgefahren, von meiner Oma aus, sind wir losgefahren, hat mich abgeholt, ich hatte
noch einen Freund dabei, von einer, nicht von einer Schule, aber jemand, den ich halt
kannte, in dem Alter, in dem Alter, wo ich noch Real-Life-Freunde hatte, das ist schon
so lange her, das kannste eigentlich gar keinem mehr erzählen, und 1998 lebte die Hälfte
hier nicht, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, ja, so, zumindest war ich so aufgeregt, weil
ich meinen ersten richtig geilen Gaming-PC, selbstgekauften, so zusammengesparten Gaming-PC
kaufe, dass ich direkt ins Auto gesprungen bin, ohne vorher noch mal aufs Klo zu gehen,
und das hat sich als Fehler rausgestellt, weil wir sind nach Aschaffenburg gefahren
im MediaMarkt, muss mal gucken, ob es das Ding überhaupt noch gibt, wahrscheinlich gibt's
das immer noch, wahrscheinlich gibt's das immer noch, ja, okay, welcher weiß ich nicht,
welcher habe ich keine Ahnung, irgendeine MediaMarkt, Aschaffenburg, so, und zumindest,
ich musste eigentlich schon aufs Klo, wo wir losgefahren sind, aber ich war so aufgeregt
und wollte unbedingt meinen Rechner holen, ich bin ins Auto gesprungen und losgefahren,
okay, easy, Problem war dann, während wir auf der Autobahn waren, war ein Stau, und
das war ein wirklich ziemlich lang gezogener Stau, und es hat sich immer länger gezogen,
und ich musste, Aldama, ich musste so krass aufs Klo, aber nur pinkeln zum Glück, nur
pinkeln, ja, Time and Currency Format, nein, kein Kokona-Time, und ich musste so übertrieben,
das ist jetzt international, ja, passt, so übertrieben pinkeln, und wir konnten nicht
nebenan fahren, ich hab zu meinem Vater gesagt, alter, fahr ran, ich muss da jetzt mal hier
in die Hecke, hat gemeint, wenn wir da jetzt nebenan fahren, da kommen wir im Leben nicht
wieder hier rein, ja, das ist total voll, ich wollte Home installieren, ich hab noch
nie Home installiert, Home ist bestimmt noch viel geiler zu deep-loaden, und irgendwann
hab ich nicht mehr ausgehalten, was hab ich gemacht, ich hab den Erste-Hilfe-Koffer genommen
aus dem Auto, hab den Inhalt rausgeschmissen, und hab das Nötigste in den Ersten-Hilfe-Koffer
gepinkelt, und das ist der Erste-Tweak-Fehler, nicht reingekackt, nur reingepinkelt, da passt
nicht so viel rein, ja, da passt nicht so viel rein, auf dem Parkplatz, auf dem Rückweg
hätte ich es fast wieder vergessen, und hab dann auf dem Parkplatz irgendwie gefühlt
10 Minuten gepinkelt, bis alles raus war, aber Leute, das war eine Erfahrung, die werd ich
nicht vergessen, das muss ich glaube ich noch mal in einem Video auf YouTube verarbeiten,
so Storys kommen mir immer gut an, Home musst du aber ohne Internetverbindung installieren,
ansonsten gibt's keinen Offline-Account, PaintChamp, okay, ich installier ohne Internetverbindung,
easy, das probier ich jetzt aus, hab ich doch nie gemacht, next, custom, wow, was ist das,
achso, das ist alte Windows, kann man das nicht alles, warum gibt es eigentlich nicht
den Knopf einfach alles löschen und gut ist, muss man da wirklich alles deliten, yes, yes,
yes, yes, next, bam, die updaten den Installer, stimmt, der Installer sieht eindeutig nach
Vista aus, den Installer haben die keinen Bock zu updaten, ja, das scheint mir echt
so, so, aber ich wollt noch ein paar Sachen aus dem Chat beantworten, während das installiert,
da hat er Piss-Champ, ne, soweit wir jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht kommen, so, irgendjemand
hat hier oben was gefragt, Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, also, ja, ja,
das wollten wir uns schon angucken, das hab ich mir schon kopiert, ist jetzt nicht wirklich
auf Tuning ausgelegt, Windows sicher anonymen und schneller machen, ich hoffe er empfiehlt
kein NordVPN, aber ich kenn ein paar Videos von ihm, ich glaub nicht, dass jemand NordVPN
ist, übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema NordVPN sind, ihr könnt euch nicht ausmalen, welche
zwei, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen Hersteller, weil das stimmt nicht, die machen das über
irgendwelche Agenturen, bei mir wieder angefragt haben wegen Werbung auf YouTube und auf dem
Stream, ihr kommt nicht drauf, Chat, ihr kommt nicht drauf, deswegen werd ich's euch jetzt
sagen, wir haben einmal YouTube Partnership, Max FPS und NordVPN und um nicht zu vergessen,
Hi Wubblers, just following up on this, Raid Shadow Legends Promotion, nur vom Feinsten
und übrigens, was ich gerade sehe, lull, was Raid, was Raid, achso Raid, Raid, ich hab
runtergescrollt, ich dachte es hat einer geradet, ja, ja, beste, ne, so und wie viel bieten
die dir, das hab ich letztes Mal vorgelesen, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr, muss ich
mal, ich guck mal nach, 2 Trailers schauen, Sponsorship, 1350 Dollar und ich krieg noch
mehr, wenn, Leute, wenn, Moment, wenn, von irgendwie, wenn, häh, 900 members of your
community reach level 100, da müssten ja 900 Leute von euch diesen Kack spielen, ja,
ganz bestimmt, jetzt mach mal, ne, mach ich nicht, übrigens Leute, wisst ihr was ich
gerade gesehen hab, wir haben doch letztens im Stream Traffic Loadbalancer gezeigt, es
hat sich lustigerweise per Mail jemand von Traffic bei mir gemeldet, hello from Traffic
Labs, Head of Community from Traffic Labs, aha, sie freuen sich, dass ich meine Knowledge
geschert hab im Stream, ah, excellent, Knowledge Sharing hier, ne, die fanden es einfach nur
cool, dass ich wahrscheinlich gar nichts, die wollten, ob ich ein paar Traffic Aufkleber
haben will und so, Max Silbermann, Dankeschön für den Sub, huge Subscription, so, ich wollt
jetzt noch ein paar Sachen im Chat kurz beantworten, bis das Windows Zeug fertig ist, also, ich
hab keine Zeit mehr, denke, ich potem wieder auf Youtube odi, nee, nein, die alte, warum
redet die denn auf einmal? Redet die in broom immer?
Press the windows, control and enter keys at the same time to turn on region.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Okay, enough intro.
Let's dig in.
Ja.
Ah komm, man kann muten.
Your region is set to Germany.
Ah komm, wir hören ihr zu.
Region, yes.
Your keyboard is set to United.
By the way, kann mir irgendjemand erklären, warum ich hier nicht einfach G drücken kann?
Und by the way, wenn meine region Germany ist, warum ist das Keyboardlayout nicht Germany standardmäßig ausgewählt?
Warum muss ich hier so hässlich runter scrollen?
Yes.
Nein.
I don't have...
Das muss ich machen, oder?
Wenn ich lokalen Account machen will, muss ich bestimmt sagen, I don't have Internet.
Just so you know, connecting to a network now could save you some time later.
Wie sie mich immer reden wollen.
Can't quit.
Choose yes.
Wie sie mich immer reden wollen.
Limited setup, ja.
Oh, black screen.
RIP.
Hä?
Moment, er startet da neu?
Oder ist jetzt kaputt?
Softlock.
Klitscht.
Ohne Internet kein Windows.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt.
Ach, jetzt darf ich. Oh, das ist aber nett.
Test.
Next.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das stimmt, was der Chat oder die YouTube-Comments gesagt haben.
Die YouTube-Comments haben gesagt, ich soll kein Passwort eintragen, dann spart man sich die Passwörter und man muss keine Security-Fragen beantworten.
Mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Scheit, das funktioniert.
Nein.
Auch nicht.
Ah, yes.
Nein, hat er jetzt me, das ist schön.
Und nix wie weg.
Kennst du die Cortana-Präsentation, als Cortana richtig gefällt hat?
Nee.
Ja, Cortana, schön.
Windows install Speedrun.
Gibt, sowas gibt es bestimmt.
Sowas gibt es 100 pro.
Haben wir das nicht sogar letzten schon mal nachgeguckt?
Doch, doch, das geht, das haben wir doch letzten sogar schon mal nachgeguckt.
Windows, Windows install Speedrun.
Ach, Arch-Speedrun hatten wir.
Platz auf Plata habe ich, ja.
Das probieren wir auch noch mal aus.
Das ist bestimmt Paynes-Champig vorkonfiguriert.
Oh, das hat, der, der Witz hat aber auch schon so ein Bart mittlerweile, ne?
Wie hast du das mit der Mobile-Seite gemacht?
Du gehst einfach hier auf die Browser-Tools und hier oben auf
diesen, diesen, äh, Mobile-Device-Test-Modus.
Und schon hast du es.
Warum nicht forever im Dark Mode?
Ich, wisst ihr, äh, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das.
Ich, wisst ihr, ich finde diese Fragen immer geil so.
Warum nicht, warum nicht Linux?
Warum nicht Windows?
Warum nicht Mac?
Warum nicht Dark Mode?
Warum nicht Thunderbird?
Warum nicht Dings?
Weil es halt nicht eingestellt ist.
Warum nicht Sub?
Rico, warum nicht Sub?
Das ist die eigentliche Frage hier an der Stelle.
Warum streamen wir nicht über Facebook Gaming oder Mixer?
Äh, schreibt doch bei vm, als würde ich mich da dran halten.
Als würde es, Zoom, wir machen eine Zoom-Session.
Schreibt doch bei vm eine Beschreibung rein.
Nee, das klappt bei mir nicht.
Mixer?
Nee, gibt's nicht mehr.
Was passiert überhaupt, wenn es, wenn man auf Mixer geht?
Was waren, was waren die, was waren die Seiten?
Mixer.com, Mixer.com.
Da kommt man direkt auf Facebook Gaming.
Haben die bei Facebook Gaming auch so ein Problem mit Pool-Streams
und Boop-Cam und, und sonstige Dinger?
Es guckt aber, na ja.
Ja, so wenig gucken, gucken gar nicht.
Sag mal.
Hä?
PUBG Mobile gucken die Leute auf, auf Facebook.
Ich finde das krass unübersichtlich.
What the fuck?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich mir hier angucken soll.
Das ist so, das ist so Paynes-Champ-ig gemacht.
Es ist, es ist ernsthaft PUBG Mobile, Alter.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Das mit den Booten war am, das wo mein Klo ist gebootet ist,
war am Hauptbahnhof in Hanau.
Kengi, danke schön, neun Monate Subscription.
Shithub Tutorial.
Ne, warum?
Du bist nicht der erste, ne wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wir wollen, dass man die Werbung ernsthaft macht.
Für was soll der Deep-Load gut sein?
Das frage ich mich auch.
Man deabonniert heute nicht, man disabot.
Okay, jetzt, weiter geht's.
Your default browser was reset.
An app cost.
Wollen die mich bei Microsoft komplett verarschen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Edge hat Probleme mit Edge?
Oder was sollen die mir sagen?
Das Ding ist frisch installiert.
What?
What the fuck?
Was, was passiert hier gerade?
Okay, wir müssen erstmal Forever Tools installieren.
Forever Tools, Forever Tools.
Und dann, und dann muss ich, dann, was?
Reinstall?
Das ist noch gar nicht installiert.
Und dann muss ich einen Snapshot machen.
Leute, erinnert mich dran, ich muss einen Snapshot machen.
Wenn ich keinen Snapshot mache, muss ich den Kram immer wieder neu installieren.
Direkt, direkt Snapshot nach Forever Tools.
Nach Forever Tools.
Cool Wins.
Ne, Weiß.
Dankeschön für 2 Monate Subscription.
Huge poggers, high IQ Subs hier wieder.
Wahrscheinlich hat Edge Probleme wegen Hardware Acceleration.
Ja, kann alles sein.
So, wir machen schon mal die wichtigsten Sachen hier.
Unpin, unpin.
Ja, kann da, unpin.
Cortana muss weg, Cortana muss weg.
Dark, wow.
Turn on Dark Mode.
Choose Dark.
Das sieht schon nicht wirklich gut aus, muss man mal sagen.
Yes.
Hast du das noch in der Sandbox aufgestellt?
Ich hab das in der VM laufen.
Ich installiere mir das doch nicht auf meinem Desktop.
Come on, bra.
Im Leben nicht.
Snapshot, Snapshot.
Ja, mache ich jetzt nach dem Reboot meinen Snapshot.
Aber der Chat, ich muss sagen, excellent Chat.
Der Chat ist heute wieder richtig auf Zack.
Hab gesagt Chat erinnert mich und der Chat erinnert mich.
Äußerst 11 hätte ich.
Sag mal, Kio-kun, kann das sein, dass du LucasM in Discord bist?
Ich hab gesehen, wir haben einen Mod, der heißt LucasM.
Und ich hab keine Ahnung gehabt, wer das ist.
Ich wollte ihn schon anmoden.
Ach, das bist du gut.
Dann hast du es jetzt offiziell bestätigt, dann hab ich es kapiert.
Ach, Discord für die Uni.
Ah, verstehe.
Snapshot1, Snapshot1, bester Name.
So, ist jetzt eigentlich der Explorer auch dark?
Ah, geht.
Äh, lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich will einfach nur, ich will einfach nur Chrome downloaden.
Ach so, Moment.
Ich will einfach nur Chrome downloaden.
Ich hab ja keinen Internetzugang an, Zack.
Kann man das jetzt einfach einschalten und dann funktioniert's?
Und er will dann nicht mit dem Microsoft-Account machen?
Äh, do you want allow your PC?
Jaja, mach mal.
Okay, Chrome downloaden.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, gehste weg.
Gehste weg.
Ich will Chrome nicht besser machen.
Ich will nicht, dass Chrome besser wird.
Ja, so.
Viel besser.
So.
Exzellent.
So, mit was wollen wir anfangen, Leute?
Nimm doch Chromium, ja, das könnte ich jetzt auch machen.
Mach ich aber nicht.
Hab ich, hab ich schon hier bei mir auf dem Haus drauf, das reicht.
Du kannst...
Geoco, lass...
Wie ist...
Am besten, jetzt weiß ich es ja, wer du bist.
Ich demode dich ja dann nicht.
Ich hab bloß gedacht, wer ist das denn?
Vielleicht irgendwie Discord gehackt oder Account gehackt oder was auch immer.
Warum nicht Opera?
Opera ist jetzt richtig toll, habe ich gehört.
Seitdem die Chinesen das übernommen haben
So Chrome, so jetzt haben wir Chrome am Start und jetzt kann ich Edge erstmal komplett wegschmeißen
Sehr gut, zack, Set Default, Bäm
Groove Music, ja Groove Music ist auch so ein Ding was keine Daseinsberechtigung hat irgendwie
Before you switch, Alter gehen wir nicht auf den Sack Microsoft. So erstmal alles weg. So also mit was fangen wir an Leute?
Wir haben wir haben zur Auswahl
Wir haben zur Auswahl, ich würde sagen, ne, chat, chat, ich überlasse euch nicht die Auswahl
Wir fangen mit dem an was die meisten Bewertungen auf Github hat. Cebaro
Na, der Cutemon wieder am Start, 22 Monate Massive Subscription hier
So ich habe einen Snapshot gemacht, Leute ich mache noch einen Snapshot
Ich mache noch einen Snapshot
Und zwar jetzt wo ich Browser und alles installiert habe
So, Snapshot 1, Beste
Hat er jetzt gemacht
Ok, also wir starten jetzt mal, 2 Jahres-Batch
Ja das, das, ähm
Kann ich dir nicht sagen
Falscher, falsches Emote
Ja, muss ich mich drum kümmern genauso wie meinen animierten 3D-Kicks
20 Rico, jetzt endlich
Jetzt kann ich dir auch beantworten
Was du wissen wolltest
Was war denn die Frage nochmal, warum kein
Warum kein Dark Mode
Ganz ehrlich, weil ich gar nicht wusste, dass vor allem wer überhaupt einen Dark Mode hat
Ich lerne das langsam, wie man das auf Twitch macht
Immer erst den Subbaiten
Und dann die Fragen beantworten
So, also ich muss mal kurz hier markieren im Chat wo ich gewesen bin
Also, wie funktioniert denn das jetzt
Der Windows 10 Deep Loader
Also das Ding hat 10.000 GitHub Sterne
Das kann schon mal gar nicht so kacke sein
Also, how to
Wie, wie funktioniert das jetzt
Crypto Tilti applique
To deep, deep load Windows
Stop Cortana
Download ZIP-File
Ok
Das hier oder was, das ZIP-File
Und jetzt
Right-Click-Power-Shell-File
Ok, machen wir, machen wir
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht
Extract, jawoll
Ok, was ist das Richtige
Right-Click-Power-Shell-File
Ja welches
Das GUI
Oder, oder was
Ok, das GUI starten wir jetzt mal
Mal gucken was passiert, ich hab echt keine Ahnung
Der natürlich
Oh, das ist ja ein Paynes-Champiges GUI, alter
Moment, mit was haben die diese GUI gemacht
Warte mal, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken
Was zum Geier ist
Was bin ich, was bin ich denn hier sehend gerade
Was, was zum
What the fuck
Button
System Wind, ach seh ich das richtig
Das ist ein Windows Forms
Windows Forms in PowerShell
Boah, krasser Scheiß
Sowas geht
Das ist ja
Ach du Scheiße, das ist ja schrecklich zu bedienen
Boah, das ist ja Wahnsinn
Muss ich gar nicht, dass das funktioniert
Ok, machen wir weiter
Customize Blocklist, remove all
Was soll ich denn jetzt überhaupt machen
Ok, PDF, Cortana, Dark Theme, enable
Edge PDF, disable Cortana, disable Edge PDF
Uninstall OneDrive
Macht das jetzt überhaupt was
Disable, oh
Ich glaub ich hab zu schnell geklickt
Oh
Ich hab's gefriest
Das funktioniert ja schon wieder gut als Zeug
Das funktioniert ja schon wieder wahnsinnig gut
Oh, oh es geht, nee
Oh
Meine Taskleiste ist weg
Lol
Meine Taskleiste ist einfach weg
Die wurde weg, die bloated
Ach nee, ah ok da sind wir wieder
Da sind wir wieder
Ich dachte die
Bloated
Bloated Taskleiste muss weg
Ok
Das haben wir gemacht
Haben wir auch gemacht
Unpin, ok
Wow
Und jetzt
Da ist irgendwas unpin
Also dafür das Xing noch da ist
Remove bloatware
Rackkeys, alles klar
Oh es hängt wieder
Also, also wisst ihr was
Es wäre definitiv nicht schlecht
Das GUI so zu machen
Dass man nach dem Klick
Nichts mehr machen kann solang es noch hängt
Vielleicht musst du es als Admin starten
Steht nichts
Steht nichts von da
Normalerweise
Kannst du mich auch fragen danach
Wer nutzt schon die GUI Version
Wahrscheinlich jeder Windows
Jeder Windows User
Außer Linux Leute wie ich
Ok
Remove bloatware
Ok hier kann man einfach klicken
Ok
Customize Blocklist, was ist das
What the fuck
Was ist denn das
Ok, remove all bloatware
Es hängt, ok wir lassen uns jetzt de-bloaten
Da steht du sollst du als Admin starten
Erster wirklich
Nö steht überhaupt nicht da
Du belet mich nicht
Du liest die zweite
Ja und
Bei first method
Ja ich mach aber die zweite
Achso
Ok das ist fail
Warum fragt mich das beim Startup nicht
Oh oh Leute es ist kaputt
Ok wir müssen es nochmal machen
Wir müssen es nochmal machen als Admin
Wie kann ich was starten
Als Admin mit Rechtsklick
Wahrscheinlich Windows Logik
Der Windows Logik nach gar nicht
Es gibt kein
Run with Power Shell
Ok also muss ich jetzt
Shift rechts ernsthaft
Wirklich
Ich hab das jetzt gemacht
Shift rechtsklick
Und jetzt run
Nö
Ne ne ne
Jebaited
Control Shift drauf
Wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache
Ich mach einfach Power Shell auf
Und sag halt Admin starten
Da waren wir jetzt einfach Schritt eins
Also
Download
Enable Power Shell
Ja ja machen wir alles
Alles gut
Und jetzt sollen wir da rein changen
Auch gut
Ne CD
Und jetzt soll ich das
Launchen ok
Hallo track and drop
Track and drop geht nicht
Das wäre ja auch zu viel verlangt
Dass das funktioniert
Security Warning
Run only kann ich scrollen
Huge
Huge Scrollerino
Was
Run
So ok
Jetzt aber jetzt kann ich richtig
Deepload Massive Deepload
Wir machen jetzt
Remove all bloatware
Jetzt funktioniert es
Da wird deeploaded
Hoch 10 deeploaded
Elect critical information
Wann kommt das nächste Video auf dem Max DPS
Kanal
Was ist jetzt
Auf DPS
Mit Overwatch 2
Ich mach grad grad nix
Ich mach nix
Chats
Seid ihr schon drin
Jonobob bei 21 monat
Dankeschön für Hyper Subscription
Oh es finished
Finished all tasks
Ok uninstall
OneDrive
Wobei das haben wir ja schon gemacht
Ah ne es hängt noch
Ok uninstalling
OneDrive
Danach machen wir noch den anderen Kram
Ok
Explorer neu starten ist anscheinend Standard
So jetzt machen wir
Die Telemetrie kommt aus
Das People icon
Ja das ist auch so ein Crap ich hab bis heute nicht gecheckt
Wozu man das People icon braucht
Wofür ist das da
Woher kenne ich das Lied nochmal
Weiß ich nicht das ist irgendeine Playlist
Irgendeine Playlist
Telemetrie has been disabled
Ok unpin
Jetzt wird unpinnt
So sind die jetzt unpinnt
Ah Leute
Alles unpinnt
Huge deepload
Was hältst du von Shia
Ich bin kurz davor
meinen alten 8 Kern Server
zu einem Shia Miner zu umfunktionieren
Remove bloatware registry keys
Alles weg
Richtig nice für mass deployment
Ich hab zum Glück
nicht von Windows nichts am Hut
Hast du meinen normalen Rechner auch schon deploatet
Nee mach ich auch nicht
Läuft ja halbwegs außer die Windows Suche
Also der Sebaro will irgendwas
Zeig ich mal her
Hast du gesehen habt den Server jetzt am laufen
Proxmox zfsrate 1
Wie auch zum Shia Miner
34TB
Das ist ordentlich
Wie groß ist denn das
Archiv jetzt gerade
3TB
Ok das geht ja eigentlich
3Ti kriegt
man sogar halbwegs günstig
Bloatware removed
Wir disablen
Edge
Wir disablen Cortana
Das Darkseam
darf an bleiben
So das war es
Jetzt haben wir deploatet
Und wir starten nochmal
Restart
Wir brauchen noch einen Prozessexplorer um zu gucken was im Hintergrund alles läuft
Ne ne wird nichts reencoded, keine Videos reencoding
Davor und danach
Die Bots von mir sind eh nicht groß weil da die ganze ziemlich effizient komprimieren
So also jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Prozessexplorer
Hier Chrome geht schon mal nicht auf
Doch, Prozessexplorer, sag mal ist Wupp Wupp ein bisschen laut gerade irgendwie
Nö passt
So Prozessexplorer Download wo ist er da
Jaja komm
Oh was ist 64a KegWaite
Ok also was läuft hier
Ok das naja so viel weniger als sonst ist das nicht
Gut das kann man jetzt schlecht einschätzen ja
Aber an sich sieht das relativ, ah Edge ist immer noch am Start ok
Ansonsten sieht das doch eigentlich
Das ist schon ein bisschen weniger als normal nicht dass das jetzt großartig wichtig wäre
Wie viele Prozesse da ein bisschen CPU Last fressen also das ist jetzt ja nicht wirklich
aussagekräftig
Ok wir sind Deep Loaded alles klar Leute ich fühl mich auch gleich viel leichter jetzt
nachdem wir Deep Loaded haben
Ansonsten was haben wir denn hier jetzt für
Was ist denn hier jetzt an das ist nix angepinnt
Das ist nix angepinnt
Hier den ganzen Müll können wir gleich deinstallieren da kann man Paint 3D deinstallieren
Weg damit
People uninstalled ah das geht natürlich nicht
Ja manche Sachen sind anscheinend noch drauf your phone und so ist auch noch drauf
Snapshot machen ne ne ich mach kein Snapshot
Revo uninstaller ach stimmt den sollte ich ja auch noch ausprobieren
Stimmt probier mal probier mal auch noch aus also Revo uninstaller
Wir sind so Deep Loaded dass ich bald mehr Ressourcen frei habe als die VM gekostet hat
Wisst ihr danach lege ich einfach 10 Deep Loaded Windows 10 VMs an und hab mehr Speicher als
vorher da wird sich das wenigstens lohnen
So also jetzt kaufen download nein nicht warum soll ich denn pro uninstaller
Aber das ist doch ein Geschäftsmodell von Microsoft oder
Die machen das so schlecht dass man sich dann pro versionen von uninstallern kaufen muss
Negative Ressources ja das ist wie negative Latency bei Stadia
8 zusätzlicher Aufräumtools hoh Portable Portable ist immer gut
Was ist das für ein Tuning Pack gerade gerade
Noch gar kein Tuning Pack sondern nur ein Deep Loaded Pack
Also by the way Leute ich sag jetzt mal ich rate ab
Ich rate davon ab so Dinger einfach drauf zu klatschen
Ohne Sinn und Verstand oder generell sowas überhaupt zu benutzen
Es sei denn man weiß ganz genau was man macht und hat irgendwelche Probleme die es eventuell
behebt aber selbst dann also eigentlich braucht man das nicht
So und jetzt kann damit kann ich Sachen uninstallen
Kann man eigentlich den uninstaller uninstallen danach wieder
Den Geek uninstaller ja das ist den Kram probieren wir als nächstes aus
So also was kann ich hier uninstallen man kann Edge deinstallieren
Ok zeige ich her uninstall Edge jawoll Edge muss weg
Was zum
Was was will das von mir Moment
Jetzt hab ich Internet Explorer ok ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich das
Richtige gemacht hab jetzt Jetzt ist der Internet Explorer die fault
Ok das ist keine so gute Idee gewesen ist das überhaupt der Internet Explorer
Das ist doch nicht der Internet Explorer das ist der das ist der alte
Das ist der alte Edge das ist nicht der Internet Explorer
Das ist der Internet Explorer das ist ach du große Scheiße wie viel Crap da drauf ist
Das ist der der Edge Edge der originale Edge ist das
Ich wusste ehrlich gesagt gar nicht dass der überhaupt noch
Dass der überhaupt noch dabei ist ok was will uns das jetzt sagen
Performing Initial En- Was was will das jetzt was genau möchte uns
das Programm da jetzt Das erinnert mich an so alte Scam Virenscanner
Was will das von mir Leftover Resources Leute wenn ich das lösche
Dann ist mein Windows im Arsch wahrscheinlich ok
Yes noch mehr Leftovers ok
So was haben wir vor immer Tools ne ne ne vor immer Tools will ich nicht
Windows Apps deinstallieren ok das ist natürlich ganz praktisch dass
man diesen Mist hier deinstallieren kann Mein Your Phone braucht kein Mensch
Ach Restore Point ist für Kack Noobs alter
Was macht das sag mal jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft also ich mein
Dass man den Kran deinstallieren kann ist cool aber hiermit machst du doch potenziell mehr
Kaputt als es was bringt ich meine als würde ernsthaft der Rechner davon
Langsamer werden nur weil da irgendwie 5 5 Registry Keys übrig sind
Kann man auch mehrere auf einmal löschen oh ne da bist ja drei Stunden beschäftigt
Ok das machen wir jetzt nicht alles was ein Schwachsinn
Ok das ist das ist was für Leute die gerne drei Stunden rumdoktern da an Windows
Kann ich oh guck mal ich kann meine Xbox deinstallieren
Ja ich weiß nicht da bin ich jetzt nicht so nicht so überzeugt von ehrlich gesagt
Man kann den Store deinstallieren Man kann den Store deinstallieren
Aber Wetter kann man den installieren Wetter ist Crap brauchen wir nicht
Wie gesagt wir machen das eh gleich wieder rückgängig und ne das machen wir nicht rückgängig
Als nächstes probieren wir das fertige ISO das fertige Deep Loaded ISO
Ok ja das ist ich muss sagen ok den Scheiß brauchen wir auch nicht ich muss sagen das
Programm macht noch einen ganz sinnvollen Eindruck weil ich sagen muss ich würde mich
damit eigentlich nicht auseinandersetzen ich würde es einfach so lassen wie es ist
Es ist ja nicht wirklich so als würde dieses Zeug jetzt wahnsinnig viele Ressourcen brauchen
noch braucht es RAM noch braucht es nennenswert Speicherplatz also man kann das einfach drauf
lassen ich meine außer man möchte halt sagen hey ich hab Cortana freies System weil Cortana
auch nicht stört wenn sie nichts macht weil Cortana ist noch das wo ich es am ehesten
verstehe
Ja so mal gucken ob das Ding jetzt neu startet oder ob es jetzt komplett broken ist
Store Experience ja Experience ist das Lieblingswort von den Marketing Leuten da
Echt die CT hat sowas jemals geschrieben ja
Don't cry so much Dankeschön für den Sub
Es ist halt Müll
Der Eichler 21 Monate hab ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen Dankeschön für den Sub
Massive Hyper Subscription
Hab ich glaub ich nix übersehen
Mau Buntu ganz ehrlich ich würde wahrscheinlich Windows benutzen standardmäßig
weil das weil es da ein paar Sachen gibt die ich nicht unter Liebungs machen kann gescheit
aber ansonsten ist mir Ubuntu oder meinetwegen auch Mau Buntu lieber was passiert denn jetzt
wenn man hier nach versucht eigentlich blub kriege ich jetzt immer noch Bing Ergebnisse
ne keine Bing Ergebnisse
Ja aber was genau hat es jetzt gebracht dass ich das deploded hab
Was genau hat es jetzt gebracht ich meine die Sachen sind nicht angepinnt die Sachen
sind weg aber die stören ja nicht wirklich ich meine man kann die wunderbar ignorieren
das ist jetzt nicht das ich sagen würde das brauche ich unbedingt
Jetzt bist du safe stimmt wir hätten Speicherplatz Leute wir hätten Speicherplatz vorher nachher
das können wir machen ich hab dann einen Snapshot
ich hab doch ich hab doch einen Snapshot gemacht das können wir jetzt mal ausbringen also
wir haben jetzt
Also wir haben jetzt verbraucht gibt es da eine bessere Anzeige
Gebt mal in der Suche eine Rechnung ein 1 plus 1
Geht nicht das kann er nicht mehr
Grip
Ähm kriegt man das hier ein bisschen schöner angezeigt
Aha used das kann man nicht copy pasten ok 18,7 Gigabyte sind used
18,7 used ok ich werde jetzt den Snapshot restoren
Mach noch mal kurz einen zweiten Snapshot
Falls ich falls ich zu dem Stand noch mal hin will
So Snapshot 1 restore und jetzt vergleichen wir das mal
Ja Processes gucken wir mal rein ich weiß nicht ob man da so viel erkennt
Beim nächsten Feature Upgrade ist bestimmt wieder alles da
Ja gute Frage wahrscheinlich ne wahrscheinlich schon
So also das ist jetzt das und das undiploted
Naja 500 mb 500 mb habe ich deploatet
Ja also ne 600 sorry Leute 600 600
Gucken wir mal Processor Explorer
Wie sieht das jetzt aus
Ja das sind ein bisschen mehr Sachen die da laufen
Aber das ist jetzt
Ich weiß nicht ob das es jetzt so wahnsinnig bringt
20 Prozesse weniger ja aber was bringen gestartete Prozesse machen
Sie jetzt ja nicht wirklich großartig aus
Die brauchen zwar minimal RAM und vielleicht ab und zu mal CPU Cycle oder so
Aber also das überzeugt mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht großartig
So aber jetzt wir sind ja noch lange nicht am Ende
Das war ja nur der erste deploating Step
Jetzt jetzt fahren wir die harten Geschütze auf Leute
Jetzt jetzt fahren wir die harten Geschütze auf und zwar
Jetzt nehmen wir das deploatet das deploatet Windows ISO
Und zwar Moment
Ja Windows 10 TGF April 2021
Ohje ich ahne Schlimmes
Oh Gott oh nein oh nein oh nein
3 Minuten da Leute
Ok das wird Paint Champ richtiger Paint Champ
Ich werde übrigens für alles die gleiche Windows VM nehmen
Also das heißt danach habe ich eine Snapshot Size von wahrscheinlich 30G oder so
Aber ich habe ja erst letztens meine Festplatte aufgeräumt
Das heißt ich habe ein bisschen Platz noch
Das sollte reichen für den Kram
Moment habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen bei denen auf der Webseite
Moment ich habe doch da was zum Teufel ist ein Maus Tuning Pack
Moment ESP01 was haben die was haben die da mit ESP mit der ESP Firmware am Hut
What the fuck
Ok
Maus Tuning Pack
Gut wie dem auch sei
Genau der geht dann aus Versehen zum falschen Pixel
Wie findet ihr die LTSC beziehungsweise LTSB Enterprise Version
Ich habe keine Ahnung ich kenne mich mit Windows Administration absolut Null aus
Das probieren wir auch noch aus das probieren wir auch noch aus probieren wir gleich danach
aus
Sag mal warum ist eigentlich das deploated ISO größer als das bloated ISO
Sollte das nicht eigentlich allein schon das ISO kleiner sein
Also man muss erstmal das ISO bloaten um es danach besser zu deploaten
Das leuchtet ein feels feels Batman
Ich benutze ja Windows in mehr oder weniger die Vollkonfiguration
Ja mir geht Windows auch auf den Sack
Aber also ich habe jetzt nicht gesehen wo es mir weniger auf den Sack gehen würde
Also ich habe jetzt nicht gesehen wo es mir weniger auf den Sack gehen würde
Die deploated ISO ist das gesamte OS aha
Ich überlege gerade wir haben ein paar Streams wo ich Hetzner Cloud Server aufgesetzt habe
unter anderem auch mit dem Preischamp glaube ich
Aber die komplette Preischamp Architektur beziehungsweise Kisten habe ich also die abschließenden
habe ich nicht im Stream gezeigt weil ich nicht wieder aus versehen die IPs liegen wollte
dass irgendwelche lustigen DDoS Leute an Start kommen
Das läuft ja nicht umsonst durch Cloudflare
Ja deswegen muss da Sebaro mal pushen wieder
Der Qt Mod muss wieder updaten
Ja also mein Notepad läuft in Wirklichkeit auch im Docker
Das fällt euch vielleicht nicht auf aber in Wirklichkeit ist das ein Container
Ein Linux Container mit Wine der da ein Notepad ausführt
2021 machts möglich
Gar keinen dort wo ich meine Domains habe der hat keine DNS API
Tja gute Frage nächste Frage
Falls dein Server anbieter die Möglichkeit hat Domains zu registrieren dann würde ich
es wahrscheinlich über den machen dass ich dort direkt mit verwalten kann
Warum gibt es noch kein Wupp Eier Ja Emote weil noch keiner eins gemacht hat
Aufmacht Download
Schneller Downloaden
Ein Kicks da gäbe ich dir recht da muss ich aber entweder auf Pfeifer eins beauftragen
Der Patrick muss eins beauftragen oder der Chainlord macht irgendeins
Als nächstes gibt es erstmal einen entsprechenden 3D Kicks von Pfeifer
Das wird lustig mal gucken ob das wie das funktioniert
Wann probieren wir Windows Server im Stream aus
Chat ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher Haben wir nicht Windows Server mal ausprobiert
vor zwei Jahren und es war extrem Painz Champ Kann sich da vielleicht noch jemand dran erinnern
Das Mouse Tuning Pack ok das können wir uns dann angucken
Ihr habt die GUI war Painz Champ Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern
Schau dir mal Vim Witch an Das ist ja im Prinzip sowas
Jetzt ist auf GitHub Window Image Customizer
So ist der Download jetzt fertig jawoll
Mac OS Server Test Stream Gibt es das überhaupt noch
Haben die das nicht eingestellt vor ein paar Jahren Mac OS Server
Gibt es das noch Ok jetzt können wir das ausprobieren
Also Deep Loaded Windows ISO Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was da auf uns
zukommt Ultra ist das auch noch
Das ist nicht einfach nur irgendeine ISO Das ist ein Windows 10 Tuning Pack Ultra
So von CD Booten
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob auch schon der Installer
schon Deep Loaded ist Nee aber Installationssprache Deutsch
Das Painz Champ mich schon mal Na gut kann man später ändern jetzt installieren
Ok Es sieht noch nicht so Deep Loaded aus
Ich hab kein Key Ist es möglich den Mac OS ISO her zu bekommen
Ja aus dem Apple Store Gibt Skrips die bauen hier das zusammen
Ok jetzt muss ich das ich glaube Leute ohne Mist ich hab diesen Installer noch nie auf
Deutsch gesehen Nicht zugewiesener Speicher auf Laufweg
Null Alles klar
Du benutzt nur noch Windows weil auf Linux nahezu keine Games laufen das kann ich verstehen
Das ist ja auch einer der Hauptgründe warum ich noch Windows verwende ich verwende Windows
wegen Spielen und halt wegen so Sachen wie Sony Vegas und so was
Und halt auch Hardwareunterstützung ja aber ansonsten ja ja das kann ich schon verstehen
Sollten Games unter Linux mal ordentlich laufen dann hat sich alles erledigt weil wenn Games
drunter laufen bedeutet das auch dass es halbwegs gescheite Hardwareunterstützung gibt auch
für die neuesten Grafikkarten sonst würden Games nicht gut laufen
Jo und andere Probleme hätten sich auch erledigt aber das wird nicht passieren
Deswegen werden wir nach wie vor Windows und Linux brauchen und für mich ist die optimale
Kombination immer noch Windows als Host Linux in LVM fertig aus
Tag ne Thai T T ARC T ARC wie auch immer zwei Monate Subscription
Dankeschön für den Sub
Naja ich benutze es halt ne und warum sollte ich warum sollte ich es nicht mal benutzen
Ich hab mir sogar mal eine Lizenz gekauft vor 5 Jahren oder so
Ich hab ja auch noch Vegas 13 oder was hab ich Vegas 13
Super Storm PC 14 Monate das ist ja schon massive Subscription hier
Das ist nicht mehr Sony ja das haben die verkauft ne
Ja das stimmt schon das stimmt schon wobei es auch nicht an Linux selbst sondern an dem
Umfeld und auch der Handhabung mancher größeren Open Source Projekte geht
Ich mein guck dir mal an wie ewig das gedauert hat bis Video Decoding unter Linux im Browser
richtig funktioniert hat
Also für das das es Deep Loaded ist guck mal ich glaube es hängt
Ne es hängt nicht
Da hat man sich lieber 5 Jahre lang die Schuld gegenseitig zugewiesen so nach dem Motto
Grafikkartenhersteller, Grafikkartenhersteller, Browserhersteller, Decoding, Codec Leute,
irgendwelche Lizenzdiskussionen, dann Wayland, X, Gedöns und sonst was
Klar jeder hat da sicherlich seinen Anteil dran
Aber das ist halt ein Problem was total viel zerredet wird an manchen Stellen
Deswegen dauert das auch so ewig
Und ganz ehrlich wenn ich mir die Windows Desktop Umgebung angucke finde ich keine gut
GNOME gefällt mir nicht KDE gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt mittlerweile noch weniger
Wobei Qt mir deutlich lieber ist als GTK
GTK ist an sich ja, das ist zwar mal gestartet als Cross Platform GUI Library ist es im Prinzip
auch aber das break bei jeder GNOME Version
Und ansonsten du hast nur so halbgare Dinger deswegen hab ich auch deswegen hab ich auch
einfach i3 und gut ist
Deploated ist es
Es ist so deploated das es ja schon gar nicht mehr bootet
Der PC konnte nicht ordnungsgemäß gestartet werden ok
Also was machen wir jetzt
Sie müssen Wiederherstellungstools verwenden wenn Sie kein Installationsmedium oder Gerät
besitzen verwenden Sie den PC
Ich bin der PC Administrator Windows
Ok drücken Sie die Eingabe Tastung um es erneut zu wiederherstellungsumgebung
Starteinstellungen
Ok Leute was machen wir was machen wir jetzt
Was nochmal neu partitionieren ich hab alle Partitionen gelöscht und hab Windows machen
lassen was es machen will
Die ist auch von Anfang an deploatet angeblich
Oh was jetzt
Das hat sich einfach wieder ausgeschaltet das war echt gar nicht das hat sich einfach
wieder ausgeschaltet
Oder habt ihr das Chat
Habt ihr neu gestartet
Moment gehts jetzt
Gehts jetzt einfach
Wie jetzt funktionierts oder was
Ok
Würde mir mehr Videos zur Ausbildung Fachinformatiker wünschen
Ja ich hab ja schon recht viel ne
Aber ich mach da immer mal wieder was zu
Das war ein Feature das wollte ich erstmal erschrecken
Oh was ist das für ne Farbe
Das ist das blau wurde deploatet da ist ja so noch grau übrig
Deploatet genau
Wir wünschen euch viel Spaß ok
Was
Boah Wonka
Was seh ich denn hier
Ok wir müssen erstmal vor allem Tools installieren Leute
Warte mal ich fände den Knopf schon gar nicht mehr
Oh Moment Moment wir müssen vor allem Tools installieren sonst seh ich nix
Kann man darauf Spiele spielen wir können Super ToxCard ausbringen
Gibt es Super ToxCard für Windows
Ok das ist so die
Was war das
Alter wie soll man das
What the fuck
Sollte ich muss mal kurz
Ne ich lasse ne 2 Verbindung an
Ok CD Laufwerk was ist denn
Ach du Scheiße
Fluent Terminal
Was zum geier ist das Fluent Terminal
Was macht das da ich denke es ist deploatet
Das ist schlimmer als die Fortwinner aus
Wow warte ich seh nix mehr
Was ist das
Richtig nicer deploater aber es ist ja nicht deploatet
Es ist deploatet und getunt also was ihr jetzt hier seht
Ist ein getuntes und deploatetes Windows
Was ist denn das Fluent Terminal
Ist das irgendwie ein geforktes Windows neues Windows Terminal oder
Oder ist das einfach ein anderes Projekt
Kommt jetzt bei jedem Start wir wünschen euch viel Spaß
Ernsthaft
Das glaube ich jetzt aber nicht
Es fühlt sich auch nicht so deutlich deploatet an wenn ich ehrlich bin
Ist das 20h2
Kein Schimmer wo sieht man das
Da gibt nicht von April das müsste das aller aktuellste sein
Meine kill not respawn
What the fuck alter was
Was ist das
Welche ausgeburten Spurs seh ich denn hier
Ach du scheiße
Ich wollt einfach nur
Ok Fluent Terminal
Das ist das aktuellste glaub ne
Ne 20h2
Moment
Müsste es nicht schon 21h1 geben
Oder kommt es erst noch
Für VMWare ist das sehr schnell
Ne
Das ist exakt das ist exakt genauso schnell
Wie die andere Windows VM auch
Ich mein es hat keinerlei Animationen und so
Deswegen kommt es einem vielleicht schneller vor aber
Das kann doch keiner benutzen
Jetzt mal jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft also
Über Geschmack über Geschmack kann man sicherlich streiten aber
Mein Geschmack ist es nicht ich mein das ist immerhin
Das ist auch hier die Startseite ok
Ah man uBlock standardmäßig drauf
Das ist ja in Ordnung
Aber dieses lila und so meine Güte
Es benutzen Leute die auch Opera Gaming verwenden
Ich brauch mal kurz 4k Katzen Video
4k Katzen Video kurz mal gucken wie viel CPU Last das verursacht
Aber das ist VM das ist eigentlich kein
Ja übliche
Kann es anscheinend unten das Theme ändern
Stimmt warum ist das so Mac
Warum ist das eigentlich so Mac OS stylish
Ok wie ändere ich das Theme
Tuning Pack Exe
Jetzt geht es los
Und hier haben wir Systemsteuerung
Ohne Scheiß Leute ich weiß nicht mal wo das Fenster anfängt und das Fenster aufhört
Willst du uns unterstützen
Nein
Alter was ist das
Was sehe ich denn da
Was ist das denn alles
Ich komme da nicht klar drauf
Kann man die Schriftgröße vielleicht ein bisschen größer machen
Ja anpassen
Ah das wurde weg deploatet
Ich glaube der Dialog zum anpassen vom Display wurde deploatet
Do nicer meinst du das ernst
Das ist ja schrecklich
Die haben sogar irgendwelche utf
Encoding probleme
Ah jetzt gehts
Ah hier 150
Ok jetzt erkennt man ein bisschen was
Ok kann ich irgendwie ich muss mal das Theme ändern
Tuning Pack
Ah wie ändere ich denn die Optik hier
Was ist da warum habe ich da ein Auto
Park Control alle CPU Kerne sind aktiv
Was ist da alles drauf
Intelligent Standby List Cleaner
Hier Theme Thema habe ich jetzt ausgeführt aber da ist nichts passiert
Ne das passiert nichts wenn ich das ausführe
Ach so das Theme Menü wurde ja deploatet
Sehe ich das richtig man kann das noch nicht mal umstellen jetzt
By the way mein Desktop ist gecrashed mein Desktop hängt
Der Desktop ist kaputt
Ne also jetzt mal ernsthaft
Ne nicht wirklich also ernst also ne
Also wirklich nett ah jetzt geht er wieder
All new explorer
Ne ok jetzt gucken wir uns das Tuning Pack nochmal an
Was man erkennt noch nicht mal wo Buttons hier anfangen und auch wenn das sieht aus
Wie Windows 95
Warum benutzt man sowas
Make FPS Rain
Was hier kann einiges kaputt gehen ah easy mach einfach
Schließen
Oh ne jetzt ist gecrashed
Oder irgendwas
Was soll das machen ich habe keine Ahnung
Ich weiß es nicht
Leute ich habe ernsthaft kein Blassen Schimmer was
Das ist ja eine Monstrosität
Monstrosität
Ist das Classic ist die Classic Shell
Ok sag mal gibt es keinen stink normalen
Ok Settings kann man die Settings irgendwie starten
Ne die Windows Settings sind deploatet
Es gibt keine Windows Settings mehr
Es gibt nur noch das Control Panel
Ne ne ne ne ne Leute also ernsthaft das nein nein
Das verwenden wir nicht
Du klingst wie Uge das glaube ich nicht
Ne ne ernsthaft das nehmen wir nicht
Was jetzt kommt wenn wir schon dabei sind
Wir probieren jetzt dieses andere Ding aus
Wir probieren jetzt dieses andere ISO aus hier
Mal gucken ob das besser ist
Hier guck mal das ist schon deploatet ISO
Moment ich brauch Telegram um das zu downloaden
Quer der KI so
Das muss von Achieve Ork laden
Aja ok mach ich mach ich
Ach hier ISO Download da ist es doch
User Malte
Torrent
Ok Achieve Ork
Und dann soll ich was runterladen
Das da das da soll ich da runterladen
Kann man den Scheiß nicht mal anklicken
Haben wir gibt es da vielleicht ein MD5 für
Was lade ich mir hier überhaupt für Dinger runter
Das kann man doch nicht das kann man doch alles nicht ernsthaft
Also ruhigen Gewissens empfehlen oder
So wie Leute wie wäre es mal mit veröffentlichten von
Irgendwelchen Checksum dass ich überhaupt überprüfen kann ob das das richtige ist
Gibt's nicht zwei Stunden
Ok Moment mal das kann man das kann man fixen
Das kann man fixen
Sekunde jetzt zeige ich euch mal Massive Tricks 17
Checksum ist bloated wir download managen das jetzt
Checksum ist bloated ja gibt's nicht
Kannst du auch noch schnell das ultra full ISO von
Das war doch das war doch ich hab doch das ultra ISO gehabt gerade
Was haben wir hier noch laufen ah KegWaite haben wir hier noch laufen
Bester weiß man sofort Bescheid wenn man KegWaite noch laufen hat
Archive Org
Doch kann es auch sein dass es es für für Windows gibt
Wir machen das jetzt download und zwar hier ISO Image
Copy Link Minus K nee
So ging das glaube ich da haben wir nämlich schon mal Sachen
Untergeladen
Bam vier Minuten Leute Outplayed outmoved outdownloaded
Oh nee sie haben es gemerkt Leute sie haben uns ertappt
Sie haben uns ertappt
Es geht wieder hoch
Das ist ein Kommando Zeilen Linux Downloader
Sie haben sie haben uns ertappt was machen wir denn jetzt
Ok wir können das downloaden einfach was anderes machen in der Zwischenzeit
Ja ok das ist wahrscheinlich in 20 Minuten ungefähr fertig
Ihr könnt noch was anderes davon ausprobieren also
Gut den Kram lassen wir runterladen
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute man kann doch nichts davon wirklich ruhigen Gewissens empfehlen
und sagen hey vertrauenswürdige Quelle Open Source Inhalt mag eventuell theoretisch noch
sein weiß ich jetzt nicht
Das wirkt doch alles also alles was wir heute ausprobiert haben doch irgendwie
Das ist wobei das erste ging aber weil es war halt direkt von GitHub
Du kannst dir alles angucken alles so ein bisschen shady oder
Ich mag gnome nicht
Leute chat warum mag ich den gnome nicht
Der Chat hat es verstanden so ist gut
Excellent Chat
Also wie gesagt ich werde dazu noch ein paar Videos machen
Als nächstes mache ich ein Video
Also nächste Technik Videos sind einmal die besten 5 Programmiersprachen zum einsteigen
ins Programmieren
Das ist aber Collaboration mit ich kann es nicht schreiben richtig aber ihr wisst was
ich meine Video zusammen mit ihm
Das laden wir auf beiden Channels hoch
Dann mache ich noch eine Collaboration mit jemand anderem wird dann aber erst geleakt
wenn es soweit ist wo wir uns über den für uns perfekten IT Arbeitsplatz unterhalten
mit Arbeitsplatz meine ich nicht Schreibtisch sondern Arbeitsplatz also die perfekte Firma
wo man hingeht oder was für uns so die perfekte Firma wäre und was uns nervt oder was wir
quasi
Als pluspunkte sehen neben mehr Geld mehr Geld mehr Geld ist natürlich immer ein Punkt
der von Vorteil ist aber es gibt durchaus Punkte die auch noch interessant sind die nicht automatisch
immer gleich mehr Geld bedeuten müssen zum Beispiel mit dem Niklas mit dem Niklas müsste
ich echt mal ein Video aufnehmen
Woher wisst ihr überhaupt dass der Niklas heißt habe ich das mal aus Versehen gesagt
im Stream
Ach jetzt habe ich geleakt nein nein nicht der Niklas nicht der Instagram Niklas den
kenne ich überhaupt nicht ich kenne ein paar Videos von ihm nein nein den meine ich nicht
ich kenne auch mehr Niklas
den meine ich nicht
Technik vom Saturn jetzt ist es raus
ich glaube nicht dass diese ISOs überhaupt nennenswert FPS bringen
kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen da ist also da funktioniert die Hälfte nicht mehr
du kannst ja nicht mal in die normalen Windows Settings reingehen
Welches Vmware Tool Vmware Workstation Beste
Macht mal ein Download 16 Minuten Leute es geht voran
das haben wir ja gerade gestartet das war dieses Ding mit Fehler in der in der Schrift wo
dann Üs nicht richtig geladen wurden und so
ich auch denke im Jahr 2021
2022 wird das Jahr des Linux Desktops
es gibt eine Sache was die machen können dass es das Jahr des Linux Desktops wird
die müssen Compets wiederbeleben und Wobbly Windows und Wobbly Windows default für alle
machen
dann könnte das was werden also aber ich ohne Wobbly Windows sehe ich nicht wie das was
werden könnte
mache es erstmal besser das ist immer das beste Argument wisst ihr wisst ihr was ich
noch viel es gibt zwei sachen ich weiß dass du mich jebaiten willst
aber es gibt zwei sachen die die finde ich immer richtig painstampig
als erstes wenn Leute sagen ich wie gesagt ich meine ich meine ich dich ich weiß dass
das jebait ist die sagen nach dem motto machs erstmal besser nur dann kannst du dazu was
sagen
Schwachsinn kompletter jebait
ja ich kann beispielsweise ohne dass ich selbst Gitarre spielen kann oder Klavier spielen
kann und sonst was erkennen wenn es einer nicht kann
das ist kein Problem oder wenn einer Schäpp spielt
so und eines also das schlimmste Argument oder Argument in Anführungsstrichen was Leute
bringen können ist getroffene Hunde bellen
kennt ihr das
da kriegt das das triggert mich immer so hart wenn man wenn irgendwie wenn du zu irgendwie
was sagst ja so hier da und das war nicht so gut und so ja ja getroffene Hunde bellen
das ist das schlimmste als das da flippe ich immer aus wenn die Leute so solche Scheinargumente
bringen
Dogue coin
Revios was ist denn Revios hat das was mit dem Minecraft YouTube Menschen zu tun
was ist das Revios
das sieht das sieht auch schon mal super deploatet aus
der Asimov Telemetrie klein ich dachte Asimov ist eine AWP skin
was soll denn das jetzt schon wieder sein
ok
was soll was soll das denn jetzt warum gibt es so viele komischen deploatet Projekte
ok Revios Github gibt es das gibt es die Grundlage
irgendwie
und und was was was was was ist das jetzt überhaupt
ich check null
ok probier mal heute heute wird der ganze Schwachsinn ausprobiert
Download Google
diese Download Quellen die sind alle schon so super Vertrauens erwecken erstmal mega
und ok erstmal mega Download machen
Sekunde Sekunde Leute sorry jetzt jetzt wird es mal wieder Zeit
Moment Moment Moment
es ist mal wieder soweit
endlich endlich haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gehabt
ich hoffe Kim Kim strikt mich nicht
Masi Dankeschön für zwei Monate Subscription
mittlerweile ist es schon so lange her die Leute erinnern sich nicht mehr an mega Upload
und es gibt Leute die sind in dem Jahr auf die Welt gekommen
dass die sind heute 10 wenn man einen alten PC noch benutzen will der zu lahm ist dann
sollte man einfach die neuen PC kaufen wenn es nicht drauf läuft was man haben will
mega Upload
ich frage mich bis heute wussten die um was es geht bei dem Projekt für die was aufgenommen
haben
wer ist das die anderen habe ich schon mal gesehen
ok das weiß ich gar nicht wer das ist
M E G A
Floyd Mayweather war das nicht ein Boxer
nein das ist definitiv nicht Mike Tyson da weiß ich wieder aussieht
richtig Banger Song Martin Dankeschön 21 Subscription
Alper Subscription ja
das ist er selbst das ist er selbst der da spricht oder
ist 10 times faster 9 minuten noch leute
ok komm mega mega wobei moment moment moment
das mega und das mega hat ja miteinander gar nichts
was ist jetzt los mein Browser ist gefriest
keck wait ah jetzt gehts wieder ok
also jetzt mal ernsthaft kann ich den scheiß runterladen oder fange ich mir da irgendwie
los mit ein
ok
wie machst du das mit deinem Betriebsleben machst du dual boot
ne kein dual boot
bist nett in der vm
ja ne das iso brauch ich ja auf dem host dass ich das installieren kann
Kim meinte mal er würde mega nz nicht mehr vertrauen
ja gut das sind ja irgendwelche chinesen denen das jetzt gehört denen würd ich da auch nicht
vertrauen
aber mega upload hab ich mega vertraut spätestens seit dem song
was ich mir grad für so nen song mach der kann die leute nicht bescheißen
wie machst du das mit deinem betriebssystem wie gesagt kein dual boot
ich hab das in der vm laufen check it out
das ist so dumm aber irgendwie auch geil ich weiß das ich hab echt voll gemischte gefühle
auf der einen seite find ich das übelst dumm aber auf der anderen seite ist geil
der mega upload song
die hatten doch keine ahnung was die da aufgenommen haben oder
so genug jetzt so wie siehts mit dem download aus
wie viel kim den wohl gezahlt hat du meinst wie viel die an kim bezahlt haben oder
die china chinesen die das gekauft haben weiß ich kann man wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwo
nachlesen
also ich benutze um das jetzt nochmal zu zeigen wie das mit der vm geht
ich hab multiple desktops unter windows wobei ja lustigerweise das einzige was nicht virtualisiert
wird bei virtuellen desktops der desktops ist
ich hab ich hab mehrere desktops und auf dem zweiten desktops hab ich einfach
find my workstation fullscreen laufen und kann mit shortcuts hier dazwischen switchen
ach für das video wahrscheinlich haben die den sonst irgendwas erzählt
wann lässt du dich impfen ja ja wenn ich nen termin hab
ich bin prioritätsgruppe 3 weil ich ja zuständig bin für kritische infrastruktur
passt mal also hört euch das mal an ne also ich arbeite quasi in der it bank infrastruktur
oder sonst wie und sie sind der meinung ich bin so kritisch ich bin priorität muss priorität
strophe 3 sein
äh weil ich mich registriert also ich hab mit dem termin ich hab letzte woche schon
gesagt ich will nen termin haben und dann haben die gemeint ja das könnte in hessen
august werden
so
ey umso länger dauer homeoffice geht umso besser
hab ich noch platz jetzt hier eigentlich
ich mein man muss jetzt auch mal ganz realistisch sehen
natürlich gehör ich zur kritischen infrastruktur und muss stufe 3 sein
es gibt jobs da gehts um menschenleben ja und es gibt jobs da gehts ums geld
und ich arbeite in nem job wo es ums geld geht dann ist ja klar wer prioritätsgruppe
3 wird und wer nicht
selbstverständlich bin ich prioritätsgruppe 3
eindeutig sonst hätt ichs ja nicht gekriegt
ich verstehs auch nicht so genau aber stonks stonks ist halt größer
vielleicht größer gleich menschenleben aber eher größer menschenleben
und was kümmerst du dich bei der bank intern infrastruktur oder payment gateways
ja das kann man nicht so also nein payment gateways sinds nicht
und es würde auch also wenn ich meinen job nicht mehr machen würde
würde jetzt auch nicht irgendwie geldautomaten nicht mehr funktionieren
oder so also
ich weiß es auch nicht ehrlich gesagt warum ich prioritätsgruppe 3 bin aber ich will
mich mal nicht beschweren
mal gucken weil ich dran komm
wie gesagt die haben mir schon gesagt es kann august werden
oh leute ich muss mal
hat jemand ne ahnung wie das beim friseur jetzt eigentlich ist
ich muss mal wieder zum friseur
was kostet denn eigentlich grad so ein corona spuck spucktest
corona quick
du kannst zwei kostenlose machen
ja aber die tests in dem testcenter da kriegste so und kriegste da nicht so ein so ein wattestäbchen
in die nase gerammt
ich glaube ich glaube einen selftest geht beim friseur auch oder
weil du kannst ja mit dem selftest auch ins möbel in in in in baumarkten so in möbel
kaufen
moment du darfst zum friseur du darfst du darfst in ein möbelhaus mit nem selftest
aber zum friseur nicht oder was
ok ok wir gucken jetzt mal nach
friseur hessen selbsttest
aktuelle infos
hier selbsttest vor ort
aber vor ort einen selbsttest durchführen der auch ein negatives rw
und mit regelung für vollständig geimpfte person
das check ich jetzt nicht
warum kann man das nicht einfach mal irgendwie klar kommunizieren was man jetzt machen muss
das geht mir schon seit der ganzen korona geschichte einfach so krass auf den sack
einfach sagen was sache ist was wie wo ist das kann doch nicht sein das gilt in hessen
ok
äh
soll ich mir test ja welcher test
weißt du was ich frag einfach mein friseur die müssen es wissen
das wäre mal gut ja
das wäre mal gut
so was macht der download 50 sekunden leute gleich haben wirs
gleich haben wirs geschafft
und ich brauche mal kurz ich brauche mal ganz kurz ein bisschen zackigere musik wartet
mal
wartet mal
bist du gläubig ja umso mehr rgb umso besser
ne bin ich nicht
bin ich nicht
ich bin noch in der kirche ich bin noch nicht ausgetreten
ich weiß noch nicht ob ich austrete aber ich bin
einer der ungläubigsten menschen die man sich so vorstellen kann
auf der anderen seite muss ich sagen ich hab auch nix gegen leute
die die irgendwie gläubig sind solange die mich in ruhe lassen und nicht versuchen wollen
mich zu bekehren das ist das was mich nervt ansonsten sollen
die alle machen was sie wollen
solange es mich nicht betrifft können die machen was sie lustig sind
wobei ich sagen muss dass mit kirchen also dass mit mit kirche austreten ich bin da
ich weiß es nicht ob ich das machen soll
ich fände es ja an sich
also ich gehe da beispielsweise weihnachten auch mal ganz gerne also nicht zum beten oder
so nur mal so ne also Richtung kirche und auch mal rein aber ich bete da nicht oder
so
ich finde das an weihnachten war ganz nett
ich fände es blöd wenn es das so nicht mehr gäbe
so ne mischung aus gewohnheit tradition und
keine ahnung so jetzt haben wir den kram downgeload jetzt muss ich erstmal rüber kopieren auf
mein host
ja downloads was tun wir denn wo ist es denn
ah wo ist ame 2 heißt das ok ame so heißt es iso
huge iso copy paste iso
sehr schön
da da sind wir so das heißt das probieren jetzt aus
machen wir die lungs vm aus und gehen mal zu windows
ich werde mal meine snapshots glaube ich
ach komm scheiß drauf
doch ich lösche meine snapshots
außerdem außer den ersten den ersten lösche
andere brauch ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
so also windows cd rein
und welche wollten wir jetzt noch mal ausprobieren die ame wollten wir ausprobieren das soll
ja angeblich
super schnell und ultra deep loaded sein und relativ nah an windows dran
schauen wir mal ich bin gespannt cd press
jetzt aber ein receiver erst habe ich gerade erst downgeloaded von mega von mega ent sind
co ent set
ja da bin ich aber mal gespannt ob das also mal die die verdriebswege sind schon äußerst
shady wo man den kram herkommt
Reactor S haben wir uns mal angeguckt vor einer ganzen Weile, das ist aber ja komplett
unbenutzbar.
Language Install, komm ich mach jetzt einfach immer Next, ich hab keinen Bock hier noch
30x Windows zu installieren und alles immer genau anzuklingen.
Ist Cloud Gaming empfehlenswert?
Nein, ich find Cloud Gaming ist für nichts sinnvoll.
Selbst bei aktuellen GPU Preisen, Cloud Gaming suckt.
Richtig hart.
Und das Gelaber von Stadia mit negativ Latency und sowas ist natürlich auch Blödsinn.
Also Stadia ist, selbst Google hat keinen Bock mehr auf Stadia.
Ja, also selbst Google, ich mein die haben nicht umsonst ihre Studios dicht gemacht,
die übrigens nie was released haben.
GeForce Now, ja also wenn überhaupt, ich hab ja auch schon Game Streaming gemacht halt
in der Wohnung.
Vom Desktop PC rüber zum Fernsehen und so, da hab ich sogar mal ein Video gezeigt.
Was ist negative Latenz?
Ja da musst du mal den Google Stadia Mensch fragen, der gesagt hat auf Stadia negativ
Latency, dice confirms, reveal date, ja im Juni haben wir doch irgendwo gesehen, haben
wir doch schon gesehen.
Google Stadia claims negative Latency.
Hallo, tja ok es scheint schwierig zu finden zu sein, zumindest haben die Leute bei Stadia
mal erzählt, sie hätten negative Latenz und die haben das damit begründet, dass die
Spieler ja quasi alle bei Stadia vor Ort auf dem gleichen Server sind und deswegen
die Latenz ja quasi negativ ist zu dem was man sonst hat.
Dass man nach wie vor eine Ausgabe zurückschicken muss, ich weiß nicht, das war so eine typische
Marketing Bullshit Nummer von Stadia.
Das ist richtig, HyperPaintsChamp, gibt es sowas eigentlich, HyperPaintsChamp, angeblich
gibt es das, HyperPaintsChamp, wie, da ist es aber doch angeblich.
Scammed, ist weg, oder es ist geblockt, vielleicht war das so ein anstößiges Emote wie Salami,
Salami ist ja auch so ein Emote, da weiß man nicht so genau, ob das, ist das das Foto
von dem Entwickler oder was, was ist das, das ist jetzt, das war jetzt die, Moment,
Moment, ich sag's euch, die AME Edition, Emollerated, oder was auch immer, was war User, User und
dann Malte, was wir uns hier heute für eine Kacke angucken, Alter, ich fass es nicht.
Flow690, ich hab besser Spiele als die, danke für die Hyper Subscription, Renew.
Warum hat der Typ ein Bild von sich im Hintergrund, what the fuck, okay, es sind schon mal gute
Sachen vorinstalliert, da bin ich ja, bin ich ja ein, bin ich ja schon mal zufrieden,
ja.
Okay, wir müssen Fire Ember Tools installieren, Windows 10 AME war mal ganz okay als das Projekt
begann und jetzt, es ist ein bisschen G-Bait Bild, Moment, ist das, ist das der größte
G-Bait aller Zeiten, der hat eine komplette Windows ISO gemacht, nur um Leute zu G-Baiten.
Ups, geht auch noch, Pain Dove, zum Glück ist es das gleiche Passwort.
Ich hab echt, also hätte ich das auf meinem richtigen System erzählt, hätte ich wirklich
Angst, dass ich jetzt irgendwie Bitcoin Miner hätte oder so.
Was sagst du, das hast du mich doch schon fünfmal gefragt im Stream.
Restart now, okay, machen wir Restart.
So und, okay, okay, was sagen die jetzt nochmal, Windows AME, was sagen die jetzt nochmal,
ist da dran so toll, also, stable, non-intrusive, yet fully functional Build of Windows 10,
Spyware Systems, bla, bla, okay, irgendwie getunt und deploatet und hast du nicht gesehen.
Du hast den Job bei EECOM 21 bekommen, exellent, kratz, kratz, wie man da früher in MMOs hätte
man nicht gesagt kratz, sondern man hätte gesagt gz, kennt noch jemand so ein bisschen
MMO-Speak, gz, das ist G-Bait, G-Bait-Hintergrund, der macht mich fertig.
Okay, also, ich finde ja die Standard-Auswahl schon mal nicht verkehrt, vom Firefox und
vom Thunderbird, das ist drauf, das ist auch in Ordnung, aber wo ist denn jetzt der Vorteil
hiervon, ich mein, das ist ein normales Windows 10, das sind anscheinend, okay, es ist eine
komische Startmenü, ah, das ist Open Shell, die haben das Startmenü ausgetauscht, die
haben das neue Windows Terminal drauf, okay, das ist gar nicht mal so übel, naja, aber
mal ganz ehrlich, dafür brauche ich doch jetzt kein extra, okay, wie viel Plattenplatz,
wie viel Plattenplatz haben wir, okay, wir verbrauchen ungefähr 2 GB weniger als eine
normale Windows 10 Installation, versuchen wir ein Update, wie man kann nicht updaten,
und man kann nicht updaten, und in die Windows-Settings kann man auch nicht, oder, das ist ja auch
toll, was, Windows-E, ah ja, oh Gott, Update, aber man kann kein Update machen, oder, Update,
ne, wie man kann kein Update machen, die haben das Update ausgebaut, ja, warum denn das,
wie soll ich das denn updaten, geht die Internetverbindung, no Internet, die no Internet, doch verbunden,
no Internet, aber ich kann zu Mozilla, alles klar, Netzwerk-Treiper sind bloat, ja, die
müssen weg, okay, und was genau davon ist jetzt der Vorteil, okay, wir ziehen nochmal
einen Prozessexplorer, aber wenn ich das nicht updaten kann, wie bekomme ich denn dann Updates,
jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, also gerade in Windows ohne Updates ist ja doch Doppel-Paints-Champ,
PowerShell das Update-Triggern, ich weiß nicht, wie das geht, Malte, KB-Manuell-Installier-Nerse,
okay es sind halt deutlich weniger Prozesse am Laufen als beim anderen, aber ich mein,
ist ja auch klar, es ist ja auch nix drauf, noch nicht mal ein Update, aber PowerShell
drauf, oh man, so was soll ich jetzt, was muss man machen, was, wo, ne ist nicht drauf,
Update, ja, was, Start, Start, ne gibt's nicht, Start, wo, gibt's nicht, okay, aber das ist
doch dann gar nicht benutzbar, wenn ich nicht mal Updates bekomme, das ist doch, das ist
doch alles irgendwie komplett witzlos, ganz ehrlich Leute, ich bin, ich fühle mich durch
diesen Stream heute echt bestärkt in dem, was ich die ganze Zeit schon sage, dass sowas
komplett der Unsinn ist, so eine Sache haben wir noch zum ausprobieren und das ist das
deep-loadedste von allen anscheinend, und zwar, Revios, was schon 21h1 ist, wie geht
denn das überhaupt ist, wann ist denn das, wann kommt denn das raus, das ist noch gar
nicht raus, also sie haben schon was, was noch nicht mehr rauskommt, was noch nicht mehr
raus ist, Beta, was bringt das nächste Windows-Update, zeig mal, was haben die wieder, computerbild,
sehe ich ähnlich, wobei ich noch nicht mal Deep-Load-Skrips laufen lassen würde, also
ich verstehe nicht, warum das Leute benutzen, was ich mir da heute so gegeben habe, keine
Ahnung, leuchtet überhaupt nicht ein, warum benutzt man das, ich meine, es gibt bestimmt
ein paar Leute, denen ist der Computer zu lahm und die reden sich dann damit ein, hat
der Freund auch in meinem Chat geschrieben, die reden sich dann damit ein, damit wird
es dann irgendwie besser oder so, das kann ich mir aber nicht wirklich vorstellen, was
ein Blödsinn alles, dann meinetwegen, also gut, für Spiele halt nicht, aber wenn man
einfach damit so basic Sachen machen will, wie im Internet rumgucken und so ein paar Standard-Sachen,
dann sollen sie sich irgendwie in Ubuntu mit XFCE und ohne großartigen fancy Oberfläche
drauf machen, oh, gut ist, da kann man das wenigstens verwenden, oder aber Wallpaper-Engine
und RGB, da wird es nachweislich schneller durch, also der ganze Geschichte wäre ich
heute echt nicht schlau. Ja, so manche Sachen verstehe ich ja, wenn Leute sagen, sie wollen
keine Bing-Ergebnisse und so, das ist ja so selektive einzelne Sachen, die nerven, verstehe
ich ja. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie ein Placebo, oder? Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
musst du, wenn du auf ein Event gehst, nicht eh fertige Hardware nehmen und darfst nur
deine Maus und Tastatur mitnehmen, also kriegst du auf irgendwelche Events nicht eh fertig
gestellt schon, dein Rechner, da kannst du doch mit Revios und so, du kannst doch schlecht
zu ESL sagen, ah Jungs, installiert mir aber bitte schön Revios, sonst spiele ich nicht.
Oder wie soll das, wie soll das funktionieren? Als ob die das machen, nee, meine ich ja,
sie meinen die wahrscheinlich nicht. Restart now, ok, jetzt wirds auch wieder Hardcore-Deploded.
Hat man bei nem Event nicht eigene Festplatten? Ich habe keine Ahnung, mich würd es aber
wundern, ich weiß es aber nicht. Wieso verwenden man da nicht Linux für CSGO? Wahrscheinlich
weil das dort Probleme mit Anti-Cheat gibt, keine Ahnung. Läuft CS-Native unter Linux?
Mit Anti-Cheat und allem? Also mit Anti-Cheat und ähnlicher Performance wie unter Windows?
Dann könnte man das machen, ja. Ah, die meisten Anti-Cheats gehen nicht auf Linux, ja dann,
also wenn Wack und Gedöns funktioniert, dann ja. Aber wenn, genau, das wollte ich, Rosario,
das wollte ich nämlich gerade sagen, weil wenn du, sag mal mal, ESL oder FaceHit spielst,
die wollen ja, dass du extra, extra Programme hast. Leute, dieses Ding, dieser ESL Anti-Cheat,
ne, das mussten wir bei Overwatch installieren und vor den Matches starten. So ein Rotz,
Alter. ESL Wire, genau. So ein Schund! Meine Güte, äh. Weiß gar nicht, ob das Wire war,
aber das, das war wirklich grausam. Oh, schwarzer Bildschirm und jetzt? Just a moment, just
a moment. Test. Kein Passwort, next. Not now. Ich weiß nicht, ob es ESL Wire war. Wir mussten
für Overwatch, für die, für die paar ESL Matches, die wir da gespielt haben, weil
eigentlich so wenig waren es gar nicht, wir haben bestimmt 20, 30 oder 30 würde ich mal
insgesamt sagen. Wir haben so 30 ESL Matches gemacht, bis, bis dann irgendwie keiner mehr
richtig Bock auf Overwatch hatte, aber, ähm, da musste man Overwatch über so ein ESL Ding,
das war ganz merkwürdig. Und ich weiß noch, wir hatten mal über eine Stunde Verspätung,
bis wir den Match anfangen konnten, weil die ESL Software nicht funktioniert hat und bis
dann irgendein Admin gesagt hat, ja, ihr dürft spielen ohne ESL Software. Es ging um irgendwie
den Achtelfinale aus irgendeinem Weekly Cup oder so. Hätte keinen Sau interessiert,
ja. Aber nein, das geht nicht, man braucht die ESL Software. Ich glaube, unser bestes,
unser bestes Ergebnis war, also wir waren jetzt nicht international irgendwie wirklich
da gut, ja. Also unser bestes Ergebnis in Overwatch war, glaube ich, einmal Win vom deutschen
ESL Cup und einmal nichts weiter. Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube dritter oder vierter
bei einem Weekly. Das war schon okay, aber das war jetzt nicht überragend. Also wir
waren jetzt nicht die super krassen Ultra-Pros. Oh, was ist das hier? Das, oh, okay, das ist
schon mal äußerst vertrauenswürdig, wenn als erstes, oh, jetzt ist der Desktop, äh.
Was jetzt? Punkbuster, ja, Punkbuster war ja nochmal ganz andere Zeiten. Was ist jetzt
erstmal der Bitcoin Miner drauf? Winfair, ja, die haben wirklich Beta-Build drauf. Kann
man hier updaten? Kann man hier updaten? Check for Updates. Okay, der Gram funktioniert immer
hin noch. Your organization has turned off automatic updates. Okay, dann nochmal ganz
schnell die Vmware-Tools installieren. Ah, es ist schon drinnen. Leute, die haben keine,
die haben keine Admin-Geschichte eingeschaltet. Es wird, es wird alles wie unter Win aus XP
als Admin gestartet. Kann das sein? Es gab keine Abfrage oder sonst was. Ah, okay, es ist aus.
Alles klar. Wird hier immer besser, yes. Das ist deploated und viel securer, ja. Der Dialog
wurde deploatet. Oh Mann, was Kram, Alter, was Kram. So, besser aufgelöst ist der Hintergrund
jetzt nicht, aber scheiß drauf. Internet Explorer, Internet Explorer, ernsthaft, ja. Edge gibt
es aber nicht. Ich muss einen Internet Explorer nehmen, um Kram zu installieren. Das ist jetzt
nicht in ihr Ernst, oder? Was jetzt? Was jetzt? Warum startet das nicht?
Downloads sind bloat. Meine Güte, was gucke ich mir? Okay, geht da dahinten, gehen an die
Windows-Settings wenigstens, okay. Die Windows-Settings funktionieren. Solid color. Blau. Picture.
Aber nicht noch irgendein normales Bild? Normal Windows-Hintergrund oder so? Ja, da wenigst
wenigstens solid color. Ja, okay, und was genau soll das jetzt irgendwie bringen? Ich meine,
der Windows-Store ist drauf. Okay, gucken wir mal, Plattenplatz belegt. Okay, das nenne
ich mal wirklich deploated, ja. Standardmäßig ist es 18,7, nee, 18,3G und das sind nur 10G.
Da ist schon ordentlich deploated jetzt, ja. Nicht, dass man irgendwie in irgendeiner Art
und Weise Speicherplatzprobleme hätte. Okay, guck mal, der andere Kram ist auch alles deinstalliert.
So, nochmal Prozessexplorer laden. Mal schauen. Womit deploatet? Oh, wir haben so viel Sachen
schon deploatet, das kann ich dir heute nicht aufzählen. Hast du das Chris Titus-Deploat-Skript
getestet? Nee, das habe ich noch nicht getestet. Das kann ich aber noch testen, ich habe noch
einen Snapshot davon, von einer frisch installierten. So, also schauen wir mal. Naja, ich agreee.
Okay, da muss ich sagen, da läuft jetzt wirklich nichts im Endeffekt, ne. Das, ich muss jetzt
ehrlich sagen, das macht von allen bisher den besten Eindruck. Also von diesen ganzen
fertigen OSen. Also ISOs, ja. Das scheint man in irgendeiner Art und Weise benutzen
zu können. Ich weiß immer noch nicht genau, warum und weshalb man das jetzt benutzen soll,
aber das scheint wenigstens normal, das Mindest zu sein, was man nehmen kann. Außer dass Prozessexplorer
23% CPU braucht, okay. Ich muss doch mal einen RAM deploaten, ja klar, das muss alles in
den CPU-Cache passen. Wie groß ist denn heute so ein CPU-Cache? 4MB? Ist cracked? Stimmt,
ist es aktiviert? Wo sieht man das? Wo sieht man das, ob Windows aktiviert ist oder nicht?
SLMGR gab es doch da sowas, oder? Du meinst WinFair slash DLV? Ist es jetzt aktiviert,
wo sieht man das? Activation-Settings. Unable, nee, ist nicht aktiviert. Hätte mich auch
gewundert. Okay, das lasse ich mir gefallen, dieses Ding hier. So wirklichen Sinn verstehe
ich immer noch nicht, um ehrlich zu sein, aber das lasse ich mir irgendwie noch gefallen.
Da ist wenigstens schön alles weg, wobei ich mich halt frage beim nächsten Update-Roll-Up,
ob das nicht wieder weg ist. Aber das ist in Ordnung, das kann man irgendwie noch verschmerzen.
Okay, was sollte ich jetzt noch mal probieren, hat der Chat geschrieben, ich mache einfach
den Snapshot-Restore wieder. Seht ihr Leute, das ist der Vorteil von Snapshots in der VM.
Dafür brauchen wir Snapshots. Jetzt können wir nämlich einfach wieder auf den frisch
installierten Windows 10, mit dem offiziellen ISO, können wir jetzt zurück. Probier WSL
dort aus, sah zu spät. RIP. Das Chris Titus Tech-pload-Script, das da, ne? Das da. This
is Ultimate Scripts, deep load for complete details. Und wie führe ich das jetzt aus?
Das gute VM starten? Cute VM starten. Okay, dann probieren wir das jetzt mal. Ich habe
kein Git installiert, also laden wir das mal als ZIP. Ups. Das ist immer. Okay, das
probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Also PowerShell als Admin starten, CD. Kann man da hier nicht
irgendwie so wechseln? So, also was muss ich jetzt ausführen? Was muss ich davon jetzt
ausführen? Minimal, hä? Minimal 1? Win 10, deep load. Win 10, deep load, PS1. Machen
wir mal. Oh ne, da muss man wieder, ach, diese EXAC irgendwas machen. Ne, in der Readme steht
überhaupt nichts drin. PowerShell enable. Ich weiß nicht, warum das Ding PowerShell
heißt und standardmäßig keine Skripte ausgeführt werden können. Set policy, genau das meine
ich, das meine ich. Was? Was? Blah. Yes. Okay. Run. Oh. Hey, das ist wenigstens
mein UI, was man lesen kann. Also, was sollen wir machen? Security. Disable meltdown flag,
set never prompt. Ja, natürlich low. Wer braucht schon Security? KegWade. So, wo ist
jetzt der deep load Button? Wo ist der deep load Button? Ich brauche old school Windows
Forms Programm. Action Center. Was ist jetzt passiert? Background apps. Wie? What the fuck?
Ach, das ist, das ist ein Knopf, wo direkt den Uninstaller runnt danach. Okay, da blickst
ihr auch nicht durch. Jetzt verstehe ich das. Also ich muss essential tweaks klicken. Okay,
essential tweaks. Oh, jetzt wird, jetzt wird getunt hier. Der Tuning Turbo ist gezündet.
Ich meine schon hart, wie viel Müll da drauf ist. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde es trotzdem
nicht machen. Ich würde Windows tatsächlich so lassen, wie es ist. Oder halt die Dinger,
die man deaktivieren kann, die ein Nerven deaktivieren und ansonsten halt mit dem Kram
leben. Ich glaube, auf lange Sicht ist man damit tatsächlich unter Windows am besten
unterwegs. Das geht ja schon oft genug von sich aus mal kaputt bei irgendeinem Update.
Und ob diese Sachen jetzt hier so viele FPS und Plattenplatz bringen, habe ich eh mal
eine Zweifel. Ich meine, wir haben es ja gesehen. Das ist jetzt alles nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Ich guck mal. Ich guck mal hier. Das ist, das ist noch größer als die standardmäßige
Windows Installation. Gut, wir haben jetzt ja auch die Downloads gemacht. Also es hat
sich im Prinzip nichts, nichts getan, nichts getan. Aber wir rebooten nochmal. Seit dem
letzten Windows Update kind eine Suchleiste nicht mehr. Meine Windows Suche ist auch kaputt.
Mal gucken, ob die unter dem Account geht hier. Test. Ah, da, aber da. Okay, da findet er
zumindest Teamspeak. Ach, da findet er auch Dateien. Keine Ahnung. Windows Logik. Who's
Champ. Moment, hat er jetzt schon neu gestartet? Guck mal, es gibt noch nicht mal Restart-Animation.
Es gibt gar nichts mehr. Es gibt einfach, einfach alles deploated. Alles deploated.
Sogar den Reboot, den Restart deploated gibt es nicht mehr. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit an
deine TXT da zu kommen? Welche? Welche TXT? Die da? Die da? Du willst nicht den Kram wirklich
installieren, oder? Ah ja, hier, mach. Ich paste das ruhig in Chat, aber ganz im Ernst,
ich empfehle es keinem das Zeug zu verwenden. Die haben einfach jegliche Animation und sonst
was ausgestellt jetzt. Das ist tatsächlich ganz okay. Das ist jetzt ein Default Windows
mit halt. Ja gut, jetzt hast du kein Fenster-Animation und sowas. Ja meinetwegen, ja. Es fühlt sich
schneller an. Es fühlt sich schneller an, weil es keinerlei Animation mehr hat, aber
unter der Haube ist es nicht schneller. Ah yes, Werbung. Ich habe YouTube Premium aus
Indien geholt für 3 Dollar oder 3,30 oder sowas. NAA. Ja gut, das letzte kann man verwenden.
Das davor ging auch, das war aber alles ein bisschen unsinnig irgendwie, aber im Großen
und Ganzen würde ich sagen, ich bleibe bei meiner Meinung, die ich eigentlich schon von
Anfang an hatte, diese Sachen braucht man nicht. Und selbst da glaube ich nicht, dass
es was bringt, weil die dann auch nicht auf einmal auf magische Art und Weise das flüssig
können, was vorher geruckelt hat. Ich meine, man könnte auch sein, das finde ich ist eine
gute Idee, man könnte seinen Bootsektor deploaten. Man könnte einfach nur noch von USB-Stick
starten. Crub auf den USB-Stick und Bootsektor deploaten. Was hast du verpasst, den ganzen
Krempel, den wir hier ausprobiert haben, aber ehrlich gesagt nichts dabei, wo ich sagen
würde, das ist super empfehlenswert. Schon spät, wieso, wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde
Zeit. Ja, das fehlt mir tatsächlich. Klar, warum nicht? Du brauchst halt eine SSD und
du brauchst Festplatten zum Storen oder gleich alles SSD, wobei wahrscheinlich SSD und Festplatten
zum Storen deutlich günstiger ist. Und wahrscheinlich auch sich dann dementsprechend mehr lohnt.
Nee, aber an sich schon ziemlich sinnlos. Ich meine, guck mal, was wir jetzt alles hier
ausprobiert haben, den ganzen Krempel hier. Boot Image, ich lösche das mal wieder, da
kann man schon ein bisschen Platz hier bekommen. Zack, bumm, weg. Und jetzt noch die Windows
VM löschen. Rescue hieß die, bam. Remove, warum kann ich die nicht löschen? Leute,
jetzt, weil ihr seid, weil ihr seid, noch einmal, noch einmal Qt, MoBuntu muss noch mal gestartet
werden. Nur, nur für den Chat, nur für den Chat. Ja, weeps in, weeps in. MoBuntu muss Stream
werden. Was ist das? Das ist MoBuntu. Ist der Sebaro da? Nee, ich glaube, der ist schon
wieder weg. Ich habe gesagt, dass ich den Windows Store nicht verwende, bis auf WSL
und das Windows Terminal, ja. Ich muss ja schon sagen, unter dem letzten Video auf YouTube,
da waren schon wieder so ein paar Schlaumeier da, ne? Muss man, muss man ja mal echt, muss
man ja erstmal los, muss man ja echt mal sehr, ups, muss man ja echt mal sagen, also ein
paar Schlaumeier waren da schon wieder am Start, die es wieder super, super viel besser gewusst
haben. Was ist das für eine, was ist das für eine Aussage? Selber schuld, wenn du die
Windows Suche benutzt. Hallo, ich meine, man benutzt was, was eingebaut ist und dann, dann
darf man sich nicht mal drüber beschweren, dass es nicht geht oder was? Da sind schon
ein paar Schlaumeier wieder dabei gewesen in den Kommentaren diesmal. Ich finde auch,
dass Windows so ziemlich den schlechtesten Dark Mode, das stimmt, das ist total inkonsistent.
Ich habe das Gefühl, den Windows Dark Mode haben die nur eingebaut, weil die Leute geschrieben
haben Dark Mode, Dark Mode, Dark Mode und Microsoft sich gedacht hat, ja komm, dann klatschen wir
da irgendeinen Dark Mode rein, dass die Leute aufhören, dass die Leute ihre Klappe halten.
Ja, das, das, da hat er recht, Soundanstellungen sind Horror, das ist richtig, habe ich jedes
Mal, ich muss jedes Mal, nachdem ich Homeoffice gemacht habe, hier erst mal rein und Mikrofonlevels
wieder anpassen. Schade, dass Linux auf dem Desktop immer noch so krass saugt. Hab ich
sogar draufgegangen, weil er hatte nicht unrecht. Also Linux auf dem Desktop ist gut für manche
Dinge, aber leider nicht für das, was die meisten Leute unter Windows so machen. So
wenn es halt unter, wenn es unter, über, über, mal im Internet was gucken, ein paar
ein bisschen Mails gucken, sich rausgeht. Gerade was die meisten Leute auf Windows machen
wollen, ist ja doch mal das ein oder andere Spielen, da hast du einfach unnötig, unnötig
Stressunterlienungs mit. Was, naja, das mit dem Online-Account verstehe ich schon, denn
die lokalen Accounts sind ja seit langer Zeit mit Rainbow Tables einzeln angreifbar und
relativ... What? Okay, das ist ein typischer Fall von, ich habe mal einen Begriff gehört
und schreibt es jetzt einfach in das Kommentar rein, als wäre ich der absolute Checker. Das,
was hat das, was hat, was hat das mit Online zu tun? Also, also erstens, wenn es um Vollverschlüsselung
der Festplatte geht, mit einem ordentlichen Passwort, dann bringen dir irgendwelche Rainbow
Tables nichts und egal ob Online- oder Offline-Account, wenn ich von einem USB-Stick boote, kann ich
eh direkt drauf zugreifen. Was hat das alles damit zu tun? Okay, ich muss jetzt aufhören
zu lesen. Was, ich oder der Kommentarschreiber? Ja, das habe ich mittlerweile auch mitbekommen.
Als wärst du das gewesen, als wärst du das gewesen. Passt mal auf, ich gucke jetzt nach
und dann war das wirklich. Moment, das muss, das muss der Account von der Mutter sein.
Ich habe 0,0003% weibliche Zuschauer oder so, das kann das sein. Das bist du nicht Rico,
das bist du nicht, du hast mich gebadet.
Warum so sicher? Keine Ahnung. Es wäre schon ein großer Zufall, dass ich jetzt gerade dein
Comment lese, obwohl wir vorher schon ein bisschen gebadet hatten im Chat. Kann alles
sein, aber ich glaube es nicht. Ach, die sind alle von dir, verstehe, dann ergibt das Sinn.
Oh, Wobbly Windows wieder, jawoll. Was ist deine letzte Nachricht? Nein, habe ich nicht,
was denn? Zeig mal her. Ah, hier. Wenn du in der Suchleiste ein Programm suchst, auf
den du drückst, schickt er dich auf die Sys-Steuerungsseite. Ist mir noch nicht so aufgefallen, aber klickt
nach typischem Windows-Pants-Champ. Was überhaupt? Wobbly Windows, was ist das? Moment, Bildungslücke.
Wobbly Windows, das essentiellste Feature überhaupt. Das hier, das ist Wobbly Windows. So muss
das sein. So und nicht anders, Leute. Leider geht es unter i3 nicht, sonst hätte ich es
dann sofort am Start gehabt. Davon halte ich ehrlich gesagt nichts, wenn du spielen willst,
ansonsten kannst du das machen. Du musst dich halt fragen, was brauchst du, also was brauchst
du unter Windows, was nicht unter Linux geht? Und dann, wie gut läuft das in der VM? Für
meinen Fall ist es so, das, was ich unter Windows mache, läuft nicht ordentlich in der
Windows-VM. Ich kann kein Sony Vegas und Spiele in der VM ordentlich machen. Es gibt sicherlich
Mittel und Wege, dass es ein bisschen erträglicher ist, aber schön ist was anderes. Deswegen
habe ich mich dafür entschieden, Windows Host und Linux, Windows Host und Linux in der VM.
Ja das ist nice, dass du den Weg hierher gefunden hast. Das finde ich cool, dass du so lange
am Start bist. Ich sehe das unter YouTube so oft, dass da Leute am Start sind, die mir
vom Namen her bekannt vorkommen. Und dann gucke ich nach und dann haben die teilweise
vor 8 Jahren schon Kommentare geschrieben. Schon hat. Also wie gesagt, ich mache es umgedreht.
Manjaro i3 als VM. Der Compiz war eh das beste. Das ist okay, das habe ich auch mal eine Weile
versucht, aber bin ich nicht richtig warm damit geworden. Ist aber auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt. Das finde ich nice, habe ich bei mir lokal auch laufen. GitLab ist mir mittlerweile
zu abgedreht, was du alles installiert haben musst. Das finde ich ist eine schöne GUI-Geschichte,
Web-Interface, Git-Geschichte, auch wenn man es nur alleine daheim verwendet. Ja das ist
halt typische Windows-Paints-Champ-Geschichte. So Bugs hat man leider manchmal. Ich finde
es ja eh lustig, ich habe das schon oft gesagt, dass das einzige was nicht virtualisiert ist
eben der Desktop ist bei virtuellen Desktops. Also Max und Shad, vielleicht könnt ihr mir
Klarheit schaffen. Jetzt geht es los. Habe mir Bob-mäßig ein Raspberry Pi mit einer Festplatte
über den Samba zusammen geklatscht, nur mal ein bisschen gemeinsam Netzwerk speichert
zu haben. Ja gut der Raspberry Pi ist jetzt dafür nicht so wahnsinnig gut. Reicht soweit
auch für meine Bedürfnisse. Nun habe ich nur ein bisschen Bedenken, wie sicher die
ganze Apparatur an sich ist, um auf das Netzlaufwerk zu kommen, muss man zwar an der Passwortabfrage
vorbei haben, mehr auch nicht. Die Samba User-Verwaltungsgeschichte ist schon in Ordnung.
Also da kann man sich schon grundsätzlich drauf verlassen. Zumal du hier auch noch
die Linux-Berechtigung drunter hast, dass selbst wenn jemand, keine Ahnung, dass das
Passwortabfrage umgehen sollte, hat er immer noch keine Berechtigung, wenn er nicht ein
User ist. Also ich würde sagen, der Sache kannst du schon halbwegs trauen, aber wenn
du es besser machen willst, also wenn du, also so wie ich das verstehe, du betreibst
ja quasi einen Samba Server oder sagen wir so NAS für Leute, für mehrere Leute und du
willst nicht oder du willst sicher gehen, dass das, obwohl es quasi, ob die Leute im gleichen
Netzwerk sind, du traust denen aber halt nicht soweit, dass du sagst, hey es kann jeder
alles sehen und du traust denen auch in soweit zu, dass die vielleicht auch mal da irgendwas
umgehen können. Also wenn du grundsätzlich ausschließen willst, dass irgendjemand was
lesen kann von deinen Dateien, dann musst du es verschlüsselt machen auf Samba Share
überlegen, aber wohlgemerkt kleinzeitig verschlüsseln, sonst bringt es ja nichts. Das kannst du machen.
Das macht es natürlich noch ein bisschen langsamer, aber dann hat die anderen gar keine
Chance. Und ich würde nicht anfangen mit Vera Crypt oder sowas, was ein komplettes
Laufwerk emuliert, sondern sowas würde ich dann auf Dateibasis machen, dann ist es auch
halbwegs schnell. Aber dann kannst du dir sicher sein, dass es kein anderer mehr lesen
kann. Nee, das könnte ich aber mal erzählen. Das ist eine lustige Geschichte, die kann
ich eigentlich mal auch auf YouTube erzählen. Da brauche ich nur, Leute, da brauche ich
nur einen guten Titel für. Ich brauche einen guten Titel und ein gutes Thumbnail für die
Ruby Story. EcryptFS, NKFS, genau sowas in der Richtung, meine ich. MissingNo 97, danke
für den Prime-Subscription. Für die Prime-Subscription. Huge. IQ++. Äh, ich. Du weißt nicht zufällig
ob es wirklich eine echte Linux-Installation ist. Hä? Na klar. Das hier ist eine echte
Linux-Installation. Ach nee, du meinst eine Linux-Installation von einer Festplatte in
ein Image zu konvertieren. Das geht. Das geht. Das geht. Es dürfte vielleicht, also es dürfte
einfacher sein ein Heimatverzeichnis zu Backupen und rüberzukopieren, aber das geht. Du kannst
ein Image ziehen von einer Festplatte, das geht, das kannst du machen. Es dürfte wahrscheinlich
sogar relativ problemlos funktionieren. Kennst du das? Nee. Aufle... Nee, ja gut, damit kannst
du Passwort resetten. Nee. War aber klar, dass es sowas gibt. Hat mir nicht gefallen.
Haben wir im Stream ausprobiert, hat mir nicht gefallen. Hi, es ist Yohi. Danke schön. 17
Monate Hyper-Subscription hier. Ja. Haben wir schon ausprobiert. Ich weiß nicht ob,
ich weiß gar nicht wie das hier heißt mit Sandbox oder sonst was. Äh, wir haben das
ausprobiert schon, Windows Sandbox. Nein, kann er nicht. Auch nicht mit 64-Bit. Die
CPU hat keine Unterstützung dafür, was leider das Problem ist und auch der hauptsächliche
Grund warum ich sage Raspberry Pi eignet sich nicht als Nass. Worum geht es in der Story?
Oh nee, da müsste ich jetzt die ganze Geschichte erzählen. Doch, ich kann das machen, ich kann
das machen. Ich weiß halt eh nicht ob das noch aktuell ist, ja. Ich war da das letzte
Mal vor 6 Jahren oder so drin. Kann ich machen. Am besten fände ich es natürlich, was richtig
cool wäre, wenn ich das mit irgendeinem zusammen machen könnte, der sich da auskennt. Aber
da muss ich mal gucken, muss ich mir noch Gedanken machen. Also generell ist jegliche
Hardware ohne Hardware Encryption, also Encryption Beschleunigung, ist doof für ein Nass. Man
möchte seine Platten eigentlich voll verschlüsselt im Nass haben. Allein schon aus einem ganz
praktikablen Grund. Platte rausnehmen, wenn sie kaputt ist und wegschmeißen. Wenn die
verschlüsselt ist, kannst du dir sicher sein, es kann niemand irgendwie jemals wieder was
recoveren. Und ansonsten weißt du es halt nicht. Allein schon deswegen würde ich Platten
immer voll verschlüsselt haben, zumal es auch kaum Performance Einbußen hat, wenn
du Hardware Verschlüsselung hast. Es sei denn du schreibst 10 Gigabit oder so. Dann
vielleicht. Ja Leute, es war ein äußerst nicer Stream heute. Ich glaube ich habe alle
Fragen durch. Meine ursprüngliche Vermutung hat sich bestätigt. Ich finde nach wie vor
diese ganzen Dinger kacke. Nee, machts nicht. Vielleicht ohne Hardware Encryption. Ich hab
auch Veracrypt laufen, das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Ok, vielleicht müsste ich es mal Benchmarken.
Kann man irgendwie von Linux quasi ein Image ziehen ohne Userverzeichnisse? Wenn du ein
Image ziehst vom Laufwerk, dann nicht. Dann machst du ein komplettes Image. Es sei denn
du hast verschiedene Platten oder Partitionen für deine Mounds. Du kannst ein System Backup
machen und Verzeichnisse exkluden. Das sehe ich auch so. Echt sehr merkwürdig. Du kannst
da alles machen. Ich finde es deutlich einfacher. Du hast die Sachen voll verschlüsselt und
gut ist. Nass Video ja, aber da gab es nicht so wirklich was großartig zu erzählen. Kann
ich dir jetzt schlecht sagen. Keine Ahnung. Du musst gucken, was der Stromverbrauch ist.
Und ob du PCIe Express brauchst. Wenn du PCIe Express brauchst, für zum Beispiel eine 10G
Karte, dann fällt es ja mit dem NUC schon mal flach. Brauche ich nicht. Du musst einfach
auf GitHub meine Files verwenden. Das ist meine komplette Config ist da drin. Zwar nicht
top aktuell, aber aktuell genug. Hast du alle Sachen, die du brauchst drin? Du musst halt
man Charo selbst installieren. Ok, wenn es daran hakt, dann kann ich dir leider auch nicht
sagen. Also Leute, wir sehen uns. Die Tage. Machts gut. Bis denn. See you.